[Musique]
Gelgiro, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Gelgir, je
suis actuellement l'économiste en chef
de l'Agence française de développement
qui est une banque publique à but non
lucratif qui finance des projets de
développement dans les pays des sud. Je
suis également directeur de recherche au
CNRS en économie, euh directeur de la
chair énergie et prospérité, prof à
l'école des ponts et jésuite prêtre
catholique romain.
Prêtre catholique romain. Euh lors d'une
de vos conférences, vous parlez des
images de la de l'apocalypse ?
Ouais.
Euh de tiré des évangiles, je pense.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous décrire ça ?
Donc l'apocalypse, c'est le dernier
livre de la Bible, du Nouveau Testament.
Euh c'est un livre qui essaie de décrire
de manière métaphorique, on pourrait
dire même parabolique, euh quelque chose
du sens de notre histoire ultime
et
elle a été longtemps interprétée euh
comme disons euh voilà des métaphores
qui décrivent quelque chose de lors de
la fin des temps. Et aujourd'hui, nous
sommes dans un moment très particulier
où la menace écologique est telle que
certaines de ces images devrait être
interprété de manière littérale
aujourd'hui.
Il y a quoi dans ces images ?
Il y a la l'effondrement d'une société
marchande. Donc la ville de Babylone qui
est qui est une espèce d'incarnation de
la marchandisation du monde, la
privatisation du monde qui s'effondre.
Les marchands qui disparaissent de la
planète et qui sont identifiés comme
étant l'une des causes du mal. Euh et ça
aujourd'hui, je crois que c'est tout à
fait d'actualité.
Donc il y a il y a des petits démons,
des choses comme ça, des flammes.
C'est
alors c'est un bestiaire extrêmement
élaboré qu'il faudrait enfin que
beaucoup de savants étudient hein, ont
étudié et continu d'étudier. Vous avez
un animal très important qui est un
dragon qui essae de manger la vie au
moment où elle naît.
Donc vous avez une image forte d'une
femme qui va accoucher euh alors qui est
interprétée dans la tradition chrétienne
comme étant Marie qui va donner
naissance au Christ, au Messie, mais il
y a un dragon qui est prêt à dévorer le
Messie au moment où il va naître. Et
c'est une manière de dire tout l'enjeu
de notre existence qui est est-ce que
nous cédons à la pulsion du dragon ? et
nous tuons la vie à l'endroit même où
elle n'est où est-ce que nous laissons
la vulnérabilité de cet enfant advenir
au monde euh grâce à cette femme ?
Revenons à nos moutons. On va essayer de
faire les berger aujourd'hui. Non. Euh
euh le système financier va bien ?
Non. Alors il va très très mal. Il va
d'autant plus mal que un certain nombre
de banques ont réussi à convaincre
l'opinion publique il allait bien de
sorte que la vigilance me semble-t-il
d'une partie de la société civile sur
les banques, c'est beaucoup relâché. Le
symptôme qui ne trompe pas, il y en a
deux. Le premier, c'est l'accumulation
de dettes privées. Alors, c'est ça
devient un vrai problème en France
aujourd'hui, hein. La dette privée en
France, c'est 133 % du PIB français
aujourd'hui. Euh c'est beaucoup plus que
la dette publique. La dette publique,
c'est un tout petit 100 %. Dans dette
privée, vous avez à la fois la dette des
ménages euh et la dette des entreprises
non financières. Pourquoi est-ce que
c'est problématique ? parce que ça
signifie que vous avez des tas d'acteurs
privés qui se sont endettés pour essayer
de alors pour les uns de survivre. Là,
c'est le surendettement de la précarité
pour les autres d'investir euh quand ils
y arrivent et euh ils sont piégés parce
que ils doivent absolument rembourser et
rembourser un peu plus que ce qu'ils ont
emprunté via la mécanique du taux
d'intérêt d'usure.
Du taux d'usure. Mais pour l'instant, je
j'ai pas de jugement moral sur la
question du taux d'usure, hein, du taux
d'intérêt. En tout cas, il y a une
mécanique financière très élémentaire
qui est que
cette dette privée quand elle est trop
importante,
elle bloque l'investissement des
entreprises. C'estàd que les entreprises
peuvent plus continuer à investir parce
que l'essentiel du cash qu'elles
retirent de leurs activités, il faut
qu'elles utilisent pour rembourser leurs
dettes.
d'une et de deux si elles ont pas assez
d'activités florissantes, elles font
faite et en faisant faillite ou en
repoussant en négociant des des remises
de dettes ou bien des un délai
supplémentaire pour rembourser leur
dettes, elles mettent en difficulté le
secteur bancaire lui-même. Alors, dans
un pays comme la France, ça veut pas
dire que la France elle-même va être
l'épicentre d'une nouvelle crise
financière majeure peut-être, mais enfin
c'est pas immédiat. Euh en revanche, au
niveau mondial, on a une telle
accumulation de dettes privées que je
vois mal comment aujourd'hui on pourrait
ne pas avoir une nouvelle grande crise.
Pourquoi ? Parce que cette dette privée
euh pour être remboursée exige donc des
revenus nouveaux qui permettent aux
débiteurs de rembourser leurs
créanciers. S'il y a pas assez de
revenus nouveaux, ils vont devoir vendre
leurs actifs, souvent les actifs
financiers qu'ils ont acheté à crédit
pour rembourser leur dettes. Et si une
masse significative d'investisseur
devient vendeur, vendeuse sur les
marchés, ça fait s'effondrer les prix.
Si les prix des actifs financiers
s'effondrent, alors beaucoup de ceux qui
sont endettés et qui jusqu'à présent
allaient bien vont eux-mêmes être en
grande difficulté et ça va donner le
craque.
Donc vous parlez d'un d'un potentiel
tsunami financier nous arrivant dessus
sur les sociétés occidentales
hyperfinanciarisées.
Oui.
On va parler crument hein. L'enfer qui
nous attend. Ça va ressembler à quoi
s'il y a des des marchés qui
s'effondrent ? les les fonds de pension,
les les ceux censés payer la retraite
des fonctionnaires,
ceux censés assurer
les allocations chômage.
Les allocations chômage et on passé des
meilleurs. Ça va ça va se matérialiser
comment ? Socialement parlant,
ça dépend complètement de la réaction
que vont avoir les autorités publiques.
Ça dépend aussi quand même en grande
partie de de l'épicentre du cyclone
si vous voulez. Si c'est par exemple la
dette étudiants américains qui est de
plus de 1000 milliards de dollars
aujourd'hui qui explose, ça sera pas la
même chose que si c'est une grande
banque publique chinoise. Ce sera pas la
même chose non plus que si c'est une
grande banque européenne. Donc ça c'est
un premier point. Et deuxième point
surtout, ça dépend de la réaction des
autorités publiques. Vous avez en gros
quand une grande banque fait faillite,
vous avez quand même deux grandes
possibilités, deux grandes options. Soit
vous décidez de nationaliser la banque
et de la sauver euh au frais du
contribuable, soit vous décidez de faire
assumer par le secteur privé et en
particulier les actionnaires l'essentiel
de la casse. Là, il y a deux grandes
options. En 2008, on a à part pour les
Man Brothers que les autorités
américaines ont délibérément laissé
faire faillite, on a constamment sauvé
les banques au frais du contribuable et
depuis lors on ne cesse de le faire.
Dernier exemple en tat Montell Pasqui en
Italie qui était
vieille banque italienne.
Ouais. La plus grande la plus ancienne
banque du monde du monde hein qui a
monté au 14e siècle. 3è banque d'Italie
qui a fait faillite en 2016 après en
gros 6 ans d'agonie porté à bout de bras
par la BCE et par Mario Dragy. Euh c'est
l'État italien qui a tout repris à son
compte au frais du contraable italien
qui n'a probablement pas bien compris ce
qui s'est passé. Voilà. Euh alors si on
a un nouveau tsunami, ça dépend des
autorités. Si elles décident comme elles
l'ont fait jusqu'à présent de sauver les
banques au frais du contribuable, ça va
être de nouveau un approfondissement de
la crise sociale pour la plupart des
classes moyennes et des classes
populaires, voire des catégories aisées
qui font qui sont pas dans le 0 1 % euh
choyé aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
français. Donc ça veut dire qu'on on va
vers une crise sociale économique encore
plus profonde que celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui.
Les gilets jaunes, c'est les prémisses.
Les gilets jaunes, si on si cette option
là se matérialise, les gilets jaunes, ça
n'est que le début de l'introduction la
préface de problèmes encore beaucoup
plus graves. Oui.
Admettons admettons que la la la
privatisation des gains s'arrête et que
la mutualisation des pertes
Ouais.
continue.
C'est une augmentation des impôts, c'est
une augmentation du coût de la vie,
c'est quoi ? C'est les gens sont plus
payés.
Ça dépend. Oui. Bah, disons le la
trajectoire classique, c'est
on profite de
disons de l'explosion de la dette
publique. C'està-dire globalement c'est
l'État si on choisit de faire payer le
contribuable, donc c'est l'État qui va
prendre à sa charge la dette de la
banque, si c'est une banque qui fait
faillite.
Donc la dette publique va exploser. La
dette publique explosant, ce sera un
alibi de plus pour continuer de
détruire, de démanteler l'état
providence qu'on a construit après la
seconde guerre mondiale. Et donc là, ça
veut dire de nouveau des coupes sombres
ou des coupes claires si vous voulez
suivant l'image que vous voulez utiliser
dans les dépenses publiques. Donc c'est
ce qu'on voit déjà maintenant. Ça veut
dire fermeture des services publics,
fermeture des hôpitaux, des écoles,
fermeture des gares et cetera,
privatisation,
privatisation à tout bras. Ce qu' a
connu la Grèce, vous voyez. Donc d'une
certaine manière, ça veut dire le schéma
grec s'étend à une partie de l'Europe.
C'est ça que ça signifie. Et le schéma
grec, ça veut dire une privatisation de
la société grecque. Puisque, comme vous
le savez, le port du Piré a été vendu,
un bout du port du Piré a été vendu à un
armateur chinois. Une île grecque a été
vendue à un allemand. Tous les aéroports
grecs ont été privatisés et vendus.
Alors, d'une certaine manière, on le
fait déjà en France. On est en train de
privatiser Aéroport de Paris.
Euh, disons la remise en comment dire la
reprise en main d'une partie de la dette
de la SNCF préfigure une possibilité de
privatisation de la SNCF. C'est pas
impossible qu'on ait également en France
dans nos cartons l'idée d'une d'un
démantellement de la caisse des dépôts
et consignations
et d'un transfert de la liste de la
gestion du livret Aux au banque privée
qui l'orgne sur ce pactol depuis des
années. Euh donc ça aussi ça peut faire
partie des options que le gouvernement
pourrait vouloir mettre en œuvre. Donc
d'une certaine manière c'est ça qui est
assez extraordinaire en France. On a
même pas besoin d'une nouvelle grande
crise financière pour que on mette déjà
en place le programme disons la la
saignée qui a été infligée à la Grèce.
Le cas italien est très intéressant
parce que il est intermédiaire, il est
dans une situation beaucoup plus
précaire que celle de la France et il
n'est pas encore euh dans la situation
grecque.
Ce qui est clair également, c'est que la
souffrance sociale que tout ceci
provoque va très vraisemblablement
bénéficier essentiellement aux
formations politiques d'extrême droite,
c'estàd
d'extrême gauche
ou d'extrême gauche, mais pour l'instant
l'extrême gauche européenne est mal en
point. Mais vous avez raison, c'estd
formellement, il y a aucune raison que
ce soit d'abord la droite qui en profite
à ceci près que l'extrême gauche
aujourd'hui est a du mal à se
structurer. Donc c'est plutôt en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on voit en Italie
l'extrême droite qui en profite hein
puisque Jin Stelle en Italie est un
partie construit de brique et de broc à
partir du blog de BP Grillo qui est un
une espèce de coluche italien. bloc qui
est monté en fait en puissance dans les
médias italiens grâce à une société de
com a été financée par une riche famille
italienne qui avait décidé de faire de
BP Grillo un leader politique ce
qu'évidemment il pouvait pas être ce
qu'il ne sera pas puis une fois que Tin
Questell est arrivé en tête des sondages
euh ce parti d'une certaine manière est
arrivé au pouvoir Volent Nolens et D
Mayo qui est le ministre de Tin
Questelle phare du gouvernement italien
actuel est un gars qui vendait des des
tickets d'entrée dans les stades de foot
avant de faire de la politique.
et qui donc aujourd'hui a une telle
inexpérience qu'il est pied et point lié
devant Salvini qui est un vieux routier
de la de la vie politique italienne qui
permet de facto à l'extrême droite
aujourd'hui de gouverner en Italie. Donc
le le risque si on n pas la construction
d'une offre politique à mon avis
socialeécologique solide en Europe,
c'est que le scénario italien se
reproduise un peu partout y compris en
France.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
régulation des marchés financiers ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du shadow
bunking ? Qu'est-ce que vous pensez des
dark pool ? Qu'est-ce que vous pensez
des chambres de compensation ? Qu'est-ce
que vous pensez de du glasagle act ?
Ensuite, on abordera les politiques des
banques centrales.
D'accord. Ce sont d'énormes sujets. Il
faudrait je peux vous les reprendre l'un
après l'autre. Commençons par la fin. Le
Glast Tigolac, c'està-dire l'idée qu'il
faille séparer des banques de dépôts et
de crédit, des banques d'investissement,
enfin des banques disons de marché.
Euh donc pour les les auditeurs qui sont
pas complètement rompus à ce type de de
questions, le métier traditionnel de la
banque c'est de récolter les dépôts et
de faire du crédit auprès des
particuliers ou des entreprises ou
quelquefois auprès des États, mais c'est
plus rare traditionnellement. Et puis
avec la libéralisation des marchés
financiers dans les années 70-80, à la
faveur en fait de la fin des accords de
Breton Woods qui ont créer une source
d'incertitude majeure avec les taux de
change flexibles, euh le monde financier
se dit "On va proposer à l'industrie des
actifs dérivés qui sont des contrats de
protection, d'assurance contre la le
risque de change qui était un risque
nouveau puisque jusqu'à le monde vivait
dans des régimes de taux de change
fixe." Et puis comme ça a bien marché,
l'industrie financière s'est dit il y a
aucune raison de s'arrêter en si bon
chemin et s'est mise à proposer des
actifs dérivés sur un peu tout et
n'importe quoi. Donc les taux fixes
d'abord, donc les obligations puis
pourquoi pas les actions, puis les
dérivées sur les dérivés puis les
dérivées de crédit et cetera. On a même
fait des dérivées sur la météo. Donc
moi, j'ai travaillé il y a quelques
années sur ce qu'on appelle le pricing,
c'estàd la tarification de d'actifs
financiers dérivés sur la météo qui vous
rapporte de l'argent si jamais le
manteau neigeu à Courchevel première
semaine de février 2024 était inférieur
à 5 cm et obligait par exemple la
station à affermé. Donc la station a
besoin de se couvrir contre ce risque et
comme les assurances classiques ne
couvrent pas, ben elle achète un produit
financier qui la couvre ou qui est censé
la couvrir. Voilà. Donc alors les
banques du coup ont découvert que ce
type d'activité sur les marchés était en
moyenne beaucoup plus rentable que
l'activité traditionnelle de crédit qui
elle dépend fortement de l'économie
réelle. Or, comme vous avez une économie
réelle qui est en en fait en berneu
plusieurs décennies euh et qui a une
croissance très très molle depuis
plusieurs décennies euh en gros depuis
la fin des années 80, euh c'est beaucoup
plus rentable d'aller euh jepiler comme
on dit dans le dans le jargon,
c'est-à-dire euh d'aller spéculer en
fait sur les marchés financiers plutôt
que de se préoccuper de savoir si tel
PME dans la drô est rentable ou non.
Du coup, il y a un certain nombre de
banques qui ont fusionné ce genre
d'activité et en France, nous avons
quatre grandes banques systémiques qui
sont dites universel au sens où elle
cumule ces deux activités. Activité
traditionnelle de dépôt de crédit,
activité de marché
euh BNP Paribas, société générale, BPCE,
banque populaire case épargne et crédit
agricole.
Ces quatre banques là, nous sommes le
seul au monde à avoir quatre banques
systémiques dites universelles. Elles
font courir à l'économie française un
risque majeur parce que
le département
spéculation sur les marchés financiers
est complètement tributaire des risques
colossaux que tout le monde court sur
les marchés financiers et se repaye à
chaque fois qu'ils font des pertes
immenses se repayeent sur le département
crédit dépôt. Alors, ça a été
caricatural au crédit agricole où vous
avez eu en interne une guerre de
gouvernance très très profonde puisque
le réseau extrêmement puissant du crédit
agricole a protesté contre la banque de
marché la le département de marché en
disant il y a pas de raison que ce soit
nous qui essuyons vos pertes. Il
n'empêche que le crédérico a réussi à
faire en 20123
plus de 6 milliards de pertes nettes
tout compris. Ce qui veut dire que les
pertes du département de spéculation
financière étaient telles que il restait
encore 6 milliards après avoir été
entièrement épongé ou partiellement
épongé en fait par le département dépôt
et crédit. Alors pourquoi est-ce que
c'est très dangereux ? Parce que ce
genre de crise et de perte colossale est
inévitable et à cause de toute une série
de questions dans le détail desquelles
je peux rentrer et du coup ça met en
danger les comptes de dépôts des
déposants français.
Or à hauteur de 72000 €
100000 € 100000 € par compte. Ouais
100000 € par compte d'après la loi.
Or si une grande banque du type BNP
Paris bas faisait faillite alors il faut
voir que le bilan de BNP c'est quasiment
la taille du PIB français hein. C'est
c'est de l'ordre de un peu moins de 2000
milliards d'euros. Donc si une grande
banque faisait faillite comme BNP
Pariba, la France, l'État français
serait incapable d'honorer la loi de
garantie publique des 100000 € par
compte.
Euh et donc les grandes banques du type
BNP et d'autres ont un pouvoir de
chantage colossal sur l'État en disant
"Écoutez, si vous prenez telle décision,
nous sommes très mal. Or, nos bilans
sont très fragiles, contrairement à ce
qu'il raconte dans le public. Euh donc
euh donc nous allons mourir mais si nous
mourons, vous mourrez avec nous parce
que euh vous n'êtes pas capable
d'honorer vos propres engagements.
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Le le fond de
garantie des dépôts bancaires est
provisionné à hauteur de
Alors, il y a euh en fait il y a un fond
avec sans sans l'effet de levier, hein.
Non, non, non. Ouais, il y a un fond
européen qui est lié à ce qu'on appelle
l'Union bancaire européenne euh qui est
abondé par les banques elles-mêmes, qui
est destinée à sauver les banques en cas
de grosse faillite dans lequel on
devrait culminer en 2023 à 55 milliards.
55 milliards, c'est dérisoire par
rapport à la taille du bilan d'une
banque comme BNP qui est en gros un peu
moins de 2000 milliards. Bon, donc on y
est pas du tout. 55 c'est un verre d'eau
tiède pour pour éteindre les cendres
après l'incendie. Euh alors ceci fait
que alors un exemple qui qui vous montre
que c'est c'est un problème extrêmement
actuel au moment de l'effondrement du
système bancaire chez Priot.
Euh il y a eu un commissaire européen
qui a eu la très mauvaise idée de dire
"Ah ben peut-être que en fait plutôt que
de perdre de l'argent public à essayer
d'honorer les comptes de dépôts chez
Priot, on pourrait ne pas appliquer la
loi et ne pas garantir les dépôts." Et
puis 24 heures après, il s'est repris en
disant "Non, non, en fait, je me suis
trompé, c'est pas du tout ce que je
voulais dire." Voilà. Euh parce qu'il a
été averti par les banques elle-même que
si la Commission européenne commence à
dire ça aujourd'hui, les citoyens
européens vont comprendre que leur
comptes de dépôts ne sont pas garantis,
ils vont retirer leur argent. Il va y
avoir probablement un bank run. et un
bank run, ça veut dire la la faillite
immédiate de toute une série de banques.
Parce que si vous retirez les les dépôts
enfin l'argent liquide qui est en dépôt
dans les banque, elles n'ont plus euh
disons euh en gros le une partie de la
liquidité dont elles ont besoin pour
faire leurs activités. Voilà.
En France, le fond de garantie des
dépôts c'est combien le
J'ai pas de montant pour la France donc
je sais pas, il faudrait regarder. Euh
mais c'est sûr qu'il est pas du tout à
la hauteur de ce qu'ils font. Donc donc
du coup ça donne un un pouvoir de
chantage des grandes banques
universelles sur la puissance publique
qui est colossale. C'est disons le
chantage du noyer et du maître nageur.
Le noyer disant au maître nageur ne me
laissez pas enfin ne m'empêchez pas de
faire ce que je veux quand je nage parce
que si je me noie vous allez vous mourir
avec moi en venant me sauver. Parce que
vous savez que si vous voyez quelqu'un
se noyer dans une rivière ou dans la
mer, c'est le seul cas de non assistance
à personne en danger qui ne soit qui ne
puisse pas vous être imputé puisque le
celui qui va chercher le noyer peut
mourir avec le noyer. Donc cette
métaphore vaut également pour l'État et
le secteur bancaire aujourd'hui. Voilà.
Et donc ça à travers ça, il y a une
capture du régulateur qui fait que les
banques aujourd'hui dictent à une partie
de la puissance publique en Europe, aux
États-Unis, au Japon leur désidérat via
cette menace.
Donc ça veut pour en sortir et je vois
pas tellement d'autres solutions que de
mettre en œuvre une version ou une autre
du Glass Tigelact qui avait été décidé
par Roosevelt en 1933, c'est-à-dire de
couper les départements dépôts de crédit
des banques traditionnelles du
département spéculation financière. Il
se trouve que la loi Muscoici 2013
prétend le faire.
Euh, elle a été très très défendue par
une députée socialiste d'alors Karine
Berger. Et c'est une loi, on pourrait
dire d'une certaine manière célérate
puisque elle prétend couper, elle ne
coupe pas, elle ne sépare pas les
banques. Donc Frédéric Oua qui est à ce
moment-là le PDG de société générale l'a
reconnu devant l'Assemblée nationale. Il
a dit en fait cette loi va nous obliger
à filialiser, ce qui est pas coupé 1,5 %
de nos activités de marché. Donc il a
révélé à ce moment-là ce que savait le
secteur bancaire à savoir que cette loi
prétendait couper sans couper. C'est une
loi Canada si vous voulez. C'est du
whisky mais c'est pas du whisky. Euh
l'Allemagne a fait la même chose
et tout ça c'était une manière
d'anticiper les véléités de la classe
politique qui dans le sillage de du
discours au bourget de du candidat
François Hollande mon ennemi c'est la
finance aurait pu avoir l'intention de
couper vraiment.
Alors finalement, il y a quand même un
homme politique français qui a voulu
sinon couper au moins mettre une cloison
étanche. C'est Michel Barnier,
commissaire européen à l'époque qui a
proposé une directive européenne
permettant de d'instaurer une cloison
étanche entre les activités de
spéculation, disons des activités de
marché et les activités traditionnelles
de dépruit de crédit. mais il a été
malheureusement retoqué par le parlement
européen très vraisemblablement sous
influence qui a pas compris du tout
l'enjeu de la directive Barnier qui à
mon avis est excellente. Voilà donc ça
c'est un premier énorme sujet euh sur
lequel il faudra très certainement
revenir dans le cas où on voudrait où on
avait l'intention sérieuse de prévenir
les conséquences catastrophiques d'un
nouveau craque financier. De mon point
de vue la première chose à faire c'est
de séparer les banques. Puis par
ailleurs, ça libère l'absence publique
qui sort en fait du piège euh dans
lequel elle est enfermée aujourd'hui.
Alors après, vous tu as mentionné toute
une série de sujets euh du type
régulation financière, shadow banking,
euh
dark pool, euh chambre de compensation.
Alors, d'une manière globale, mon point
de vue, c'est que euh il y a un enjeu
colossal qui est euh la réécriture du
cadre prudentiel d'activité bancaire,
donc de ce qu'on appelle bal 3. Euh ce
cadre en fait met un certain nombre de
contraintes à l'activité centrale des
banques qui est le cré de la monnaie.
Donc premièrement, il faut rappeler à
tout le monde que une banque, c'est une
institution financière qui crée de la
monnaie tous les jours. Donc qui utilise
une planche habillée, ce qui est une
image hein, parce que l'essentiel de la
monnaie aujourd'hui, c'est des lignes de
code sur des écrans d'ordinateur. C'est
pas des billets de banque et des pièces
métalliques, c'est pas de la monnaie
financière. Euh donc une banque crée de
la monnaie. Si vous allez voir votre
banquier demain matin et vous lui
demandez un crédit pour acheter votre
appartement,
au moins 80 % de la monnaie qu'il va
vous prêter, c'est de la monnaie qui
n'existait pas 2 minutes avant que vous
entriez dans son bureau. Donc c'est de
la monnaie qui est créée exilo.
Et pourquoi ? Parce que une banque,
c'est précisément une institution
financière qui a reçu du roi en fait de
l'État le pouvoir de créer de la
monnaie, ce qui est tout à fait à mon
avis légitime. Jusque-là, j'ai aucune
difficulté. simplement évidemment elle
peut pas créer de la monnaie adlibitum
peut pas créer une quantité infinie de
monnaie et elle peut pas créer une
monnaie pour se sauver elle-même. Pour
créer de la monnaie, il faut qu'elle ait
un client externe qui lui demande un
crédit.
Alors premièrement, donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut encadrer les conditions dans
lesquelles elle peut créer de la monnaie
en accordant du crédit. Euh alors
aujourd'hui en fait disons depuis une
trentaine d'années, on a corseté
complètement la manière dont l'État
l'absence publique peut demander à sa
banque centrale de créer de la monnaie
pour lui. Et on a retiré en fait de la
main des États le pouvoir de création
monétaire dont il disposait en fait
grâce par exemple en France au circuit
du trésor entre le trésor et la Banque
de France jusque en gros au milieu des
années 70. Et puis avec le traité de
Mastrich, on a rendu ça impossible. On a
dit la Banque centrale européenne qui
sera la seule banque centrale de
l'ensemble de la zone euro n'aura pas le
droit de prêter directement sur le
marché primaire aux États. Donc les
États n'auront plus le droit de
s'endetter à ta nul auprès de la banque
centrale. Ils devront impérativement
s'endetter auprès des marchés
financiers. Donc on a retiré de la
puissance publique le pouvoir de
création monétaire avec toute une
rhtorique de légitimation de
l'indépendance de la banque centrale
européenne qui n'a aucun fondement
analytique. Je pourrais revenir
là-dessus tout à l'heure. Alors les
banques privées, elles elles créent de
la monnaie pas n'importe quelle
condition. Les conditions en gros pour
aller très vite c'est le le cadre
prudentiel de balle 3 qui est donc fixé
par un comité de balle qui est dans
cette charmante petite ville de Suisse.
Pourquoi ? Parce que c'est un comité qui
est rattaché à la banque des règlements
internationaux, la BRI. qui est la
banque centrale et banque centrale qui
se trouve être située à balle.
Euh là-dedans, il y a deux enjeux à mon
avis dans une réécriture de balle 3. La
le premier c'est de renforcer
considérablement les exigences de fonds
propres.
Donc une banque à chaque fois qu'elle
accorde un crédit, il faut qu'elle ait
un matelas de fond propre pour le cas où
elle serait pas remboursée, pour le cas
où elle ferait des pertes. Donc ce ce
fond ces fonds propres, c'est la
sécurité par rapport au risque qu'elle
prend quand elle accorde un crédit dans
une activité traditionnelle normale.
Aujourd'hui, les exigences de fonds
propres sont calculées à partir de
ratios qui à mon avis ont été
complètement trafiqués parce que ces
ratios mettent en regard d'un côté le
volume des crédits accordés par la
banque et de l'autre l'ensemble de ses
fonds propres. Mais le volume des
crédits, il est lui-même pondéré par la
dangerosité, la riskin en anglais, le la
mesure du risque de ces crédits. Or, qui
calcule la dangerosité de ces crédits ?
les banques elles-mêmes via des modèles
suffisamment sophistiqués avec des
bataillons d'ingénieurs et de mat dont
j'ai fait partie qui font ces calculs et
qui font ces modèles qui sont tels que
avec ça vous pouvez faire apparaître
comme non risqué des crédits extrêmement
risqués et diminuer énormément les
exigences de fonds propres de la banque.
Donc ces ratios là qui sont des usines à
gaz que les auditeurs comptables n'ont
absolument pas les moyens et le temps
d'aller inspecter et regarder jusqu'au
bout parce qu'ils ont pas le temps
d'aller regarder les modèles de finances
stocastiques qui sont utilisés par les
ingénieurs pour les calculer. Ces ratios
là à mon avis ne valent pas grand-chose.
Le ratio pertinent, c'est un ratio très
très simple que n'importe quel comptable
est capable de calculer qui est
simplement le ratio volume des crédits
accordés divisé par fond propre pur sans
pondération, sans modèle, rien du tout.
Et quand on regarde ce type de ratio, on
constate que la plupart des banques de
la zone euro aujourd'hui sont à 2 3 %.
Quelques-unes un peu au-dessus mais en
gros elles tournent à 3 %.
Au début du 20e, elles étaient à 20 %,
20 25 %. Au 19e, elles étaient à 50 et à
partir des années 80, ce ratio s'est
effondré parce que évidemment si vous
devez immobiliser des fonds propres,
vous faites moins d'affair, vous pouvez
pas payer des bonus colossaux, vous
pouvez pas payer votre PDG 1 million
d'euros par mois, c'est pas possible. Si
vous voulez faire ça, il vous faut
diminuer la contrainte des fonds
propres. Donc les d'une certaine manière
le secteur bancaire
en complicité avec une partie des
régulateurs a fait en sorte que le cadre
prudentiel de bal 3 devienne lui-même
une usine à gaz qui permette au fond de
relâcher la contrainte. Mon point de
vue, mais je suis pas du tout le seul,
il y a plein d'économistes qui disent
ça, c'est qu'il faut renforcer la
contrainte pour sécuriser les banques.
Le FMI lui-même dit que les banques sont
sous-capitalisées.
Le
jusqu'à combien faut-il monter ? Pardon,
excuse-moi. À mon avis, il faut monter
au moins jusqu'à 20 % vu la la
dangerosité de la de la situation
aujourd'hui.
Bon, pour résumer le trivialement, on a
un système financier qui est dirigé par
une bande de mégalot qui sont sur
l'accord de raide à chaque seconde
avec les fondements de la soutenabilité
de notre société. Pareil sur l'accord de
raide.
Ouais.
Euh la question, elle est très simple.
Le to big to fail.
Ouais. que tu as essayé de me décrire ce
chantage de de "On va mourir, tu vas
mourir avec nous".
Est-ce que c'est pas un chantage du
genre si les gens comprennent
Ouais
ce qu'on a fait, ce qu'on est en train
de faire et ce qu'on veut faire, on perd
notre tête. Les têtes vont rouler et les
fourches vont s'aiguiser et on va se
faire attraper.
Alors en fait, c'est ce qu'une partie du
secteur bancaire a craint en 2008.
Euh disons le cataclysme financier 2008
qui a été colossal. Il y a quand même 25
% de la capitalisation boursière du
monde qui a disparu. Euh 1/4 euh fait
que les financiers de l'époque, ceux
avec qui je discutais, ont cru ça. Ils
se sont dit "Une fois que les gens vont
avoir compris ce qu'on a fait, ils vont
nous chercher avec des fourches."
Euh donc
j'ai des anciens collègues qui prenaient
le métro en en vêtement disons commun et
qui enfilé leur costard dans l'ascenseur
de leur propre immeuble à la défense
pour éviter d'être repéré comme un
financier de de la défense idem à la
city à Londres. Voilà donc ils ont eu
très peur. Puis à partir de 2009, ils
ont vu que la puissance publique dans la
plupart des pays a géré admirablement à
leur avantage la crise financière. Euh
et euh ils ont été rassérénés
aujourd'hui. Euh je sais pas quel est
leur état d'esprit par rapport à la on
n' pas encore de nouvelles grande crise
financière, en tout cas pas apparemment.
Donc je sais pas quel est leur état
d'esprit. C'est sûr que la violence d'un
certain nombre de casseurs qui
bénéficient qui profitent du mouvement
des gilets jaunes pour faire valoir leur
propre ressentiment social peut faire
craindre le pire à un certain nombre de
financiers. En même temps, le la
puissance publique leur est extrêmement
favorable et les défendra. Donc euh
c'est sûr que ils ont cette espèce de de
crainte d'un côté et puis de d'arrogance
et de sécurité de l'autre en se disant
on est protégé par les par les pouvoirs
publics, la police et l'armée euh qui
euh comme vous le savez aujourd'hui
n'hésite pas à utiliser des armes
létales contre les gilets jaunes en
étant condamné par la communauté
internationale là-dessus en France.
Voilà. Donc
voilà. Alors après à mon avis,
il y a encore toute une série d'autres
sujets techniques que tu as abordé, les
dark pool, les chambres de compensation,
le shadow banking. Je dis quelques mots
là-dessus pour dire qu'il faudrait
évidemment réguler le shadow banking. Le
shadow banking, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Une fois qu'on a compris que les banques
ont besoin d'un client qui leur demande
de l'argent, qui leur demande un crédit
pour qu'elles puissent utiliser leur po
de création monétaire. Une fois qu'on a
compris également que dans l'économie
réelle, ça se passe mal depuis au moins
une trentaine d'années pour des tas de
raisons dans lesquels je peux rentrer,
qui fait que les banques ne font plus
assez de profit avec l'économie réelle.
Elles ont besoin de se créer des clients
artificiels, financiers qui vont leur
demander de l'argent pour qu'elles
puissent utiliser leur pouvoir de
créationétaire. Qu'est-ce qu'elles font
? Elles font Qu'est-ce qu'elles ont fait
? Elles font des des fonds spéculatifs,
des objets qui ne sont pas des banques,
des objets institutionnels, financiers.
euh où elles mettent une partie de leurs
propres salariés, leurs collègues qui
vont bosser là-dedans, qui sont
institutionnellement indépendants de la
banque mais en fait c'est des copains
qui vont demander du crédit à la banque
pour faire des opérations à fort effet
de levier que je vais décrire par
exemple des opérations de private
écoutier. Donc les copains de la banque
vont me demander de l'argent. Moi, je
vais être évidemment très heureux de
leur accorder des crédits. Je vais faire
fonctionner mon pouvoir de création
monétaire et quand leurs opérations
marchent bien, ils vont mecer avec des
taux d'intérêt intéressants. C'est ça le
shadow banking. Donc le shadow banking,
c'est je délocalise une partie des
activités que je voudrais pouvoir
réaliser dans des équipes qui sont mes
anciennes équipes à moi que je mets que
je place dans des animaux
institutionnels
hybrides qui sont pas bancaires. Donc
ils sont pas soumis à la réglementation
bancaire. en régulation.
Voilà, hors régulation et qui vont
pouvoir faire ce que moi je n'ai plus le
droit de faire comme banque avec mon
pouvoir de création monétaire puisque je
suis leur complice. Moyen en finance
évidemment. C'est ça le monde du shadow
banking. À partir de 2009, les banques
ont compris que tôt ou tard nos sociétés
sont pas stupides, elles vont être
régulées ou en tout cas craignant que ça
ne le soit le cas, se sont mises à toute
vitesse à créer à faire exploser le
monde du shadow banking pour aller
localiser hors réglementation bancaire
une part substantielle de leurs
activités. Alors l'exemple
paradigmatique de ce que fait un fond
par exemple de private equity, c'est la
chose suivante. Il repère une entreprise
qui va plus ou moins bien. Il emprunte
100 auprès de sa banque alliée complice
pour acheter l'entreprise. Avec ses 100,
il fait une opération sur l'entreprise.
Il restructure l'entreprise au pas de
charge, il vire un du personnel et bon
change le PDG. Voilà et puis 2 ans
après, il revend l'entreprise
150.
et il paye
5 à la banque et il garde 45 de
bénéfice. Donc c'est ça une opération à
fort effet levier. Ça lui permet de
faire en ayant emprunté 100 donc avec
rien. Alors admettons qu'il ait eu 10 de
capital initial pour emprunter 100. Avec
10 de capital initial il fait un
bénéfice de 45 de 450 % en 2 3 ans. Donc
c'est colossal. Aucune activité de
l'économie réelle, en particulier aucune
activité compatible avec la la
transition écologique et les enjeux
écologiques d'aujourd'hui ne peut
rapporter du 450 % en 3 ans. C'est juste
pas possible. Sur les marchés
financiers, c'est possible au prix
évidemment bien souvent de la
destruction de l'entreprise
et d'une case sociale
et d'une case sociale phénoménale.
Voilà. Alors, il faut pas non plus être
complètement caricatural. Il y a des
activités de privé equity qui ont été
utiles pour les entreprises. Je dis pas
le contraire. Il y a des gens qui ont
bien fait leur boulot dans les fonds
private equity, mais il y en a aussi
beaucoup qui ont fait n'importe quoi et
qui ont juste spéculé de manière à euh
avoir des effets de leviers colossaux
qui sont juste incompatibles avec la
réalité économique du monde infralaire
quoi.
Tu as déjà pris de la cocaïne ?
Jamais.
Est-ce que tu connais cette légende qui
dit que tous les traders, les gens dans
la finance
sont coqués à mort ?
Oui, je la connais. vont se faire des
Crame des billets, s'arrose avec des
bouteilles de champagne qui coûtent plus
de 10000 € la grosse bouteille, des
choses comme ça. H
vont dans des supers avions.
Ouais, c'est un imaginaire. Alors, il
faut euh
Comment ça c'est un imaginaire ?
Il faut euh
je pense qu'il faut
faire attention à la chose suivante. Si
on essaie de je cherche juste un film à
mon avis qui pour moi traduit fidèlement
l'expérience que j'ai eu quand j'étais
quant, c'est-à-dire ingénieur qui
faisait des maths pour les traders de
l'activité bancaire, c'est margin call.
Voilà. Là, tout ce que je vois dans ce
film est vrai. En tout cas, c'est ce que
j'ai vu. Et pour la petite anecdote,
l'un des banquiers avec lesquel j'ai
travaillé il y a longtemps, il y a il y
a 15 ans,
que j'ai appelé après avoir vu le film
Marging Cole en étant en ayant moi-même
l'impression en sortant de la salle de
cinéma de sortir du boulot, je dit
tiens, j'ai l'impression de sortir de la
banque. Je l'ai appelé et j'ai dit "Tu
as vu Margin Cole ?" Il me dit "Oh", il
dit "Qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?" Il
dit "Ah, je vois pas pourquoi les gens
s'excitent autour de ce film en fait."
ce que ce que décrit ce film, c'est la
vie. Voilà. Donc ceux qui ont trempé
là-dedans quand il voi marin disent bah
ouais c'est ça. Donc ça c'est un film à
mon avis
juste au sens où il décrit
l'étendue de ce que vivent un certain
nombre de de traders.
Il y a évidemment des traders qui n'ont
jamais touché la cque, qui n'ont jamais
loué les services d'une prostituée, qui
ne se sont jamais arrosé au champagne et
cetera. Évidemment, donc il s'agit de
pas, je veux dire, je pense qu'il faut
être un tout petit peu raisonnable dans
la manière dont on manie cet imaginaire
là.
Euh
mon point de vue à moi, c'est que les
jeunes qui sont embarqués dans la vie de
trader euh sont soumis à un risque
colossal qui est le suivant. Ils ont une
activité qui est quasi entièrement
dématérialisée en apparence en tout cas.
Donc quand il spéculent par exemple sur
les actifs dérivés, sur les matières
premières agricoles, ils se rendent
absolument pas compte de l'impact que ça
peut avoir sur le prix du blé ou du riz
dans un village d'Andra Pladev en Inde.
Donc ils mesurent pas ça du tout. Ils
sont dans leur petit bureau à Manhattan
ou à la City ou à la défense ou à
Francfort à Frankfurt Mine et il y a
rien de concret de sensible qui vient
leur faire prendre conscience de la
gravité de leurs opérations. Et d'une et
de deux, ils gagnent un fric colossale
en quelques années très jeune.
Donc à 30 ans, ils peuvent gagner
10 20 50000 € par mois
dans un climat où il se sent moins
performantin.
Non, faut pas exagérer. À 30 ans. Alors
à 40, c'est plus hein pour les plus
performants, mais à 30 ans non, c'est
déjà pas mal. Euh
est-ce que c'est pas fait à dessin qu'on
laisse des mégalomanes prépuber
archipayés jouer avec des boutons qui
peuvent créer la fin au Bangladesh ?
Est-ce que utiliser des gens qui n'ont
pas encore
Oui. Alors donc je je termine mon point.
Mon point, c'est de dire évidemment ces
jeunes là, surtout des hommes, des
garçons,
ils sont ils sont mis en risque de péter
complètement les plans. C'estàdire
d'arriver dans une espèce de folie qui
est le monde n'a plus de limite pour
moi, je n'ai plus de réel auquel je me
cogne. La contrainte budgétaire n'existe
plus, tout ce que je veux, je peux me
l'offrir. Voilà. Et ça, c'est le début
de la folie. Alors, ça peut être une
folie qui est hyper valorisée
socialement euh malheureusement, mais
c'est quand même de la folie parce que
la sagesse humaine pour moi, c'est
prendre conscience que le réel ne
s'identifie pas à mon désir.
C'est pour ça que tu as décidé
d'absoudre ton âme en rentrant dans les
ordres ?
Non, pas du tout. Non, ça n'a rien à
voir parce que euh je voulais devenir
jésuite avant même de travailler pour
les banques. Euh
et euh
j'ai été travailler pour les banques
après la mort de mon papa parce que
j'avais besoin de sous que les banques
étaient prêtes à me faire travailler à
me payer en bien.
Pourquoi bien payé ?
J'étais payé comme consultant en fait.
Alors, comme consultant, j'ai été très
mal payé pour un consultant qui fait des
maths de haut niveau, mais par rapport à
un fonctionnaire chercheur au CNRS,
j'étais très bien payé. Donc, ah ben je
peux dire un fonctionnaire du CNRS de
base, il gagne 1500 € par mois euh et
donc il est autorisé à multiplier par
deux son salaire. Voilà.
Voilà. Donc on va pas chercher, c'est
pas des sommes comme ça.
L'église, elle fait quoi pour la
régulation financière ? La Banque du
Vatican, elle fait quoi ? Est-ce que
l'ordre des jésuites a décidé de se
pencher un petit peu sur la banque du
Vatican ? Rappelons rappelons ce qu'il y
a un jésuite. Est-ce que tu as fait veœu
de pauvreté ?
Ouais. Alors, un jésuite, c'est un
religieux qui a fait
un mo de guerrier.
Ça, c'est un imaginaire qui me semble
faux, franchement pour différentes
raisons. Donc, un jésuite, c'est un
religieux qui a fait trois vœux,
pauvreté, chasteté, obéissance euh qui
sont les trois vœux classiques de la vie
religieuse chrétienne catholique. Euh
c'est pas un moine au sens où les moines
sont des religieux qui ont fait vœux de
stabilité dans un lieu, dans un couvent
en général, un monastère. Euh donc ça
par exemple, c'est les bénédictins, les
cisterciens, les carmes. Euh les
jésuites n'ont pas fait vœux de
stabilité. En fait, dans la vie
religieuse, il y a trois grandes étapes.
La vie religieuse occidentale
chrétienne, il y a l'étape des moines,
en gros, du 6e au à aujourd'hui.
Évidemment, ils sont pas, il y a
toujours des moines. Puis à partir du
13e siècle, ce qu'on appelle les
andremandiens, donc les francisquins et
les dominicains qui eux ont des couvants
mais sortent du couvent et font le va et
vienre le monde de la campagne, le monde
féodal de la campagne qui est celui du
monastère et la ville. Et puis au 16e
siècle, on a des jésuites qui eux vont
dans la ville, le monde féodal a disparu
où est en voie d'extinction et
travaillent dans la ville qui n'ont pas
d'habit monastique. Nous n'avons pas
d'habit qui ne sont pas soumis à ce
qu'on appelle la prière du cœur,
c'est-à-dire les cinq au moins cinq
prières classiques auxquelles les moines
sont soumis. Les laudes, les matines,
les vêpres, sixt, non et cetera. euh
mais qui ont une mission
d'évangélisation à l'extérieur dans le
monde. Donc ce sont pas des moines en ce
sens technique. Ils ont les les jésuites
n'ont pas vœux de stabilité. Au
contraire, ils ont un vœu de euh
mobilité pour être disponible dans la
mission. Et euh en revanche, ils
prononcent leurs trois vœux comme tous
les religieux. Voilà, c'est ça un
jésuite. Alors après pour revenir à la
question financière dans l'église et la
Banque du Vatican. La Banque du Vatican
euh a servi pendant des années
malheureusement de plaque tournante de
blanchiment de l'argent salale de la
mafia italienne. Euh et le pape François
aujourd'hui est en train de mettre de
l'ordre là-dedans de manière extrêmement
pugnaace. Évidemment, il y a des
résistances mais je crois que c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement sain que
l'église aujourd'hui fasse le ménage
dans ses propres institutions
financières.
Euh
l'église s'est prononcée de manière
extrêmement forte et précise en faveur
de la régulation financière. Donc, il y
a eu en octobre 2011 une déclaration du
ce qu'on appelle le Conseil pontifical
Justice EP justice Pax en latin euh qui
a euh
à l'initiative du cardinal Peter Turkson
qui a publié un texte remarquable dans
lequel il est dit de manière très forte
: "L'église catholique recommande la
séparation bancaire
euh séparation entre banques de dépôts
de crédit, ce dont on parlait tout à
l'heure, et les banques de marché. euh
les taxes tobines, donc la mise en place
de taxes sur les transactions
internationales d'abord et puis pourquoi
pas sur l'ensemble des transactions
financières et la fin euh on est en 2011
octobre 2011 la fin de la
recapitalisation bancaire sans
conditions. Donc à ce moment-là, le
conseil pontifical de justice dit "Nous
observons que entre 2008 et aujourd'hui
ce que la puissance publique a fait,
c'est essentiellement de recapitaliser
les banques en faillite ou en quasi
faillite sans émettre aucune condition
sur l'activité de ces banques." Ça, il
faut arrêter parce que c'est juste ce
que tu disais tout à l'heure,
c'est-à-dire on privatise les gains et
on mutualise les pertes sans aucune
contrepartie du côté de l'activité
bancaire.
Voilà. Euh le pape François a pris des
positions extrêmement fortes euh en
faveur de la régulation financière et de
la sortie d'une espèce d'idolâtrie du
monde financier. Euh je l'ai fait
moi-même par exemple euh avant que le
pape François ne soit élu euh en 2012
lors d'une conférence de Carem à
Notre-Dame que j'ai donné avec
Jean-Pierre Jouillet à l'époque qui
était le directeur général de la Caise
des dépôts qui ensuite est devenu le
secrétaire général de l'Élysée de
François Hollande. Voilà. Et donc moi,
j'ai pris position très fortement en
disant
les marchés financiers sont le veau d'or
d'aujourd'hui. Il faut sortir de ça et
les régul les réguler sans état d'âme
parce que l'utilité sociale des marchés
financiers aujourd'hui n'est pas
démontrée. Voilà. Donc je crois que la
position
du magistère éclésial chrétien
catholique est très claire.
la finance, ça se régule et nous avons
un risque majeur de d'idolâtrie
aujourd'hui des marchés financiers dont
il faut sortir. Bon, parlons un peu
d'écologie, on reviendra sur la finance
un peu plus tard.
On a un copain qui est fondateur du
programme spatial français qui s'appelle
Jacques Blamon qui a écrit un bouquin
qui s'appelle Introduction au siècle des
menace qui a été rencontré le cardinal
Noir pour lui dire voilà je suis
biographe officiel de Bon il a pas
présenté comme ça mais je suis biographe
officiel de de Galilée.
J'ai un problème, la consommation de
viande nous emmène un peu, ça va nous
créer des problèmes, les nappes
fréatiques se cassent la gueule, la
pollution, tout ça. Bon, résumé
trivialement, il leur dit voilà, vous
êtes depuis 2000 ans les meilleurs au
niveau de la propagande.
Bon, vous avez cramé deux trois
scientifiques mais c'est pas grave.
Est-ce que vous pouvez pas faire quelque
chose pour que vos fidèles fassent
prennent des disposition pour moins
consommer de viande,
respecte le climat, ainsi de suite ?
Ouais. Euh ça a pas donné grand-chose.
Ouais.
L'église, elle en est où là avec le
réchauffement climatique ? va attendre
que Jésus revienne,
qui nous sauve, qui multiplie les petits
poissons, qu' il ouvre les océans.
Notre ami imaginaire à tous, il est où ?
Alors l'église, en fait, de mon point de
vue, l'Église catholique, il y a
d'autres églises que l'Église catholique
euh a pris une position extrêmement
forte en juillet 2015 avec la
publication l'encyclique la date aussi.
Aucune institution n'avait publié un tel
texte et j'ai plein d'amis écol
d'extrême gauche ou non mais aussi
d'extrême gauche qui ont pleuré en
lisant ce texte en disant nous ça fait
40 ans qu'on se bagarre et on a jamais
été capable de produire un tel texte. Je
pense que ce texte-là
a propulsé l'Église catholique qui s'y
attendaient pas euh de la position qui
était la sienne qui était plutôt sur le
bord de la route par rapport à
l'histoire de l'humanité de nos sociétés
dans la locomotive.
Au sens où elle a dit euh un certain
nombre de messages très très forts. La
question écologique est devenue la
question primordiale aujourd'hui pour
nous.
La date aussi est très claire là-dessus.
On peut pas être chrétien et croire que
les marchés vont pourvoir et résoudre le
problème écologique. Il y a même au
numéro 123 de l'encyclique une phrase
extrêmement forte où le pape dit "Il y a
une même logique entre le viol enfants,
l'abandon des vieillards et l'idéologie
du marché qui nous sauverait de la
question écologique."
Avec les petits enfants, ça marche pas
trop bien en ce moment. L'église est en
train malheureusement de voilà de
découvrir que elle est aussi. Il
découvre il découvre pas trop quand
même. Il était au courant. Non,
moi j'
le meilleur service de renseignement du
monde c'est quoi ?
On peut en discuter. Moi j'étais pas au
courant. Euh
il y a deux choses he à mon avis il faut
pas je veux dire il faut il faut
vraiment apprendre à distinguer. Je
crois euh
c'est le cas de le dire.
Ouais. L'église aujourd'hui est prise
d'un des scandales absolument monstrueux
que je ne peux évidemment que condamner
et désavouer et il faut que la justice
passe se fasse
avec la plus extrême sévérité
parce que c'est la crédibilité de
l'église qui est en jeu. Voilà. Donc
Barbarin Barbarin une petite tape sur
l'épaule, c'est pas grave.
Barbarin,
c'est Barbarin qui a été reçu par le
pape parce qu'il voulait donner sa
démission et puis en fait non, le pape a
dit non. Alors le pape en fait l'a mis à
pied mais n'a pas reçu sa démission tant
que la procédure judiciaire n'est pas
complètement terminée puisque euh
Monseigneur Barbarin a fait appel de sa
condamnation. Voilà. Mais enfin il est
mise à pied. Voilà. Euh et par ailleurs,
comme vous le savez, euh le numéro 3 du
Vatican, lui a été entièrement
démissionné, réduit ce qu'on appelle
réduit à l'équuni
non pas excommuniier, euh exclu de
l'ordre des prêtres. Donc dans le dans
le jargon cananique réduit l'état
laïque. Donc il n'est plus prêtre si
vous voulez. On n' jamais eu une telle
sanction dans l'église. C'est la
première fois. Donc je crois qu'il faut
mettre ça au crédit de du pape François.
Je crois pas du tout qu'on puisse
accuser François d'être une espèce de
complice même par ignorance des affaires
de pédophilie. Au contraire, il essaie
d'instruire ce dossier, je crois avec
beaucoup de courage et de et le plus de
transparence possible. Voilà. Euh
ça c'est un aspect fondamental. Je suis
pas du tout en train de nier la réalité,
la gravité de cette question. Euh et ce
que je vais dire là n'est pas une
manière d'excuser l'église mais je pense
que nous tous ici là on est conscient du
fait que évidemment c'est pas un
problème purement éclésial.
Malheureusement
c'est la maladie du pouvoir.
C'est la maladie du pouvoir. On pourrait
dire tout à fait. Ce que j'observe dans
les milieux non ecclésiaux proche de
l'État et de la haute fonction publique,
c'est malheureusement très très proche.
C'est très très proche. Il y a un
sentiment de toute puissance qui d'une
certaine manière se traduit dans une
sexualité complètement désordonnée. Je
lisais l'autre jour, il y a pas très
longtemps, c'est amusant, des travaux
qui ont été faits par les étologues sur
les chimpanzés et la manière dont dans
une tribu de champanzé, on devient le
chef. Le chef, c'est celui qui est
capable de euh
faire l'amour avec les les guons
les plus charmantes du groupe. Donc
c'est celui qui est capable de séduire
les guenons et de se reproduire avec
elle. C'est lui qui devient le chef.
Donc l'enjeu de l'autorité légitime de
la du pouvoir et de la violence et de la
puissance chez les chimpanzés, c'est la
capacité à être choisie par les jolies
filles.
Vous êtes en train de nous dire que si
les femmes nous choisissaient les
meilleurs d'entre nous, le monde irait
mieux. C'est ça ?
Non, je en train de dire qu'un certain
que d'une certaine manière l'homme est
un animal métaphysique mais aussi un
animal. Et dans la manière dont il se
socialise et don il organise son
pouvoir, euh il est pas impossible queil
y ait du chimpanzé en nous. Et beaucoup
d'hommes quand ils ont le pouvoir se
disent "Ce qui me légitime, c'est que je
suis capable de me reproduire et
beaucoup de femmes très jolies si c'est
possible. Enfin peu importe, mais voilà,
il y a quelque chose dans le le lien
sexualité pouvoir qui est très puissant.
sexualité, pouvoir argent. Je dis rien
de très euh de très nouveau là-dedans.
Voilà. Donc tout ça pour dire que je
pense que toutes les grandes
administrations, toutes les grandes
bureaucraties sont soumises au même
problème que l'église. Ce qui veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas que justice se fasse
dans l'église. Mais voilà, l'église
n'est pas la seule grande bureaucratie
qui est soumise à ce problème. Et par
ailleurs, vous savez aussi que euh la
question de l'inceste dans la famille
est un sujet monstrueux et monumental.
Voilà. Donc c'est voilà, malheureusement
c'est pas propre. au clerger. Alors,
ceci étant dit, je reviens euh à la
question initiale euh qui était quoi
d'ailleurs ?
On vous a perturbé non ?
Ouais,
la Banque du Vatican. Non, j'ai répondu
sur la Banque du Vatican. Non,
mais lui il pose pas les questions, il
s'occupe juste de son clavier.
Ah d'accord. Très bien.
Sur sur la capacité de la du Vatican à
dire à ses à ses fidèles.
Ah oui, sur l'écologie, pardon. Tout à
fait. Ouais. H
vous avez beaucoup de d'initiatives qui
sont prises sur le terrain euh par des
chrétiens avec des non chrétiens. c'est
un sujet transversal qui concerne tout
le monde. Donc moi ce que j'observe
c'est qu'il y a énormément de
communautés locales qui se créent pour
essayer d'inventer un style de vie
écologique.
Un exemple, c'est le magnifique campus
de la transition écologique à Forge près
de Montre auquel je contribue, qui est
un château du 18e siècle dans lesquels
dans lequel une communauté qui vit là,
homme, femme, religieux, laïque, pas
religieux et cetera, apprend à vivre de
manière écologique. Donc ça veut dire
tout le monde est végétarien, on fait de
la permaculture, on mange les produits
du jardin et l'idée c'est que ça
devienne un centre de formation
d'apprentissage où on apprend et on vit
ce qu'on apprend. Voilà. Alors, il y a
des activités du enfin des initiatives
du même type qui sont prises dans le
monde. Je peux en citer deux au moins
parce que je les ai visité, j'ai vécu un
petit peu. Vous avez le Schumaker
College à Tutness en Angleterre et puis
le Sustainability Institute à Stellen
Bosch en Afrique du Sud. euh qui font
mutatisme mutant la même chose,
c'est-à-dire c'est un lieu de formation,
vous donnez des cours avec des étudiants
et dans le même temps, tout le monde va
faire de la permaculture au jardin,
mange les produits du jardin, toute
l'électricité provient euh de
photovoltaïque décentralisé dans le
l'échovillage alentour. Tous les déchets
sont recyclés, l'eau est recyclée et
cetera et cetera. on apprend à vivre
d'une manière qui soit compatible avec
euh
le respect disons des écosystèmes dans
lesquels des milieux dans lesquels nous
vivons. Voilà,
c'est c'est pas un peu un pensement sur
une jambe de bois ? Euh bon, pour
résumer, je vais me faire l'avocat du
diable, hein.
Ces petits camps de hippi où tout le
monde il est content, il fait son petit
chou-fleur, tout se passe bien, il fait
son petit pied de tomate. D'accord. La
ville de Paris, c'est combien de
millions d'habitants ? Est-ce que c'est
extrapolable sur
C'est une bonne remarque. C'est une très
bonne remarque. Ma réponse, elle est
c'est la suivante. C'est c'est
indispensable mais c'est non suffisant.
C'est-à-dire je crois que c'est il y a
deux écueils. Un premier écueil qui est
de croire queon va pouvoir relever le
défi de la décarbonation de nos
économies sans nous-mêmes changer notre
style de vie perso. Ça c'est juste pas
possible. Donc il faut que les hommes
acceptent de ne plus manger de viande
rouge. Voilà, c'est dur pour eux parce
que là aussi il y a un investissement.
On parlait de sexualité, de pouvoir tout
à l'heure, mais c'est un rapport aussi
avec le caractère carnivore de l'être
humain. Euh quand on mange de la viande,
on se rassure parce que on se prouve à
soi-même qu'on est tout en haut de la
pyramide des prédateurs sur la planète
et queon a pas de prédateur au-dessus de
nous. Euh voilà, il faut lâcher ça et
arrêter de manger de la viande rouge.
C'est pas du tout évident. Regardez
autour de vous les hommes adultes qui
sont qui sont végétariens.
Donc premier écueil, croire que il faut
pas changer notre style de vie le plus
élémentaire. Deuxième écueil, croire que
ça suffit. Évidemment, ça suffit pas.
Euh donc les c'est pas des petits clubs
IPI, c'est un apprentissage existentiel
profond de la manière dont je dois
changer mon mode de vie. Dans le même
temps, il faut évidemment que la
puissance publique et le section privé
change complètement de braquet sur la
question écologique.
Est-ce qu'ils sont prêts à faire ça
quand on voit que, si je peux me
permettre d'utiliser des grands mots,
cette oligarchie politique
formatée depuis des décennies, voir
certaines générations de depuis des
générations.
Est-ce que tu sens ce basculement, ce
changement de paradigme au sein même de
nos élites quand on les voit s'augmenter
? en arrivant dans les ministères
euh quand on les voit comme ça se
balader,
tu comprends ce que je veux dire ?
Ouais, ils sont très bien.
Il y a à mon avis alors de nouveau comme
pour les traders tout à l'heure, je
disais il y a aussi les traders qui qui
touchent pas à la coque et cetera. Euh
il y a aussi des politiques qui ne se
grattent pas le nez aussi hein.
Ouais. Il y a aussi des politiques qui
qui bossent et qui ont compris les
enjeux écologique. Voilà. De mon point
de vue et ça rejoint un tout petit peu
ce qu'on se disait il y a quelques
temps, le lieu de la résistance la plus
profonde c'est la finance.
C'est pas tellement la classe politique.
La classe politique en fait quand même
aujourd'hui a compris la gravité de
l'enjeu.
Il vient d'où Macron ? Macron, c'est un
haut fonctionnaire euh de l'Inspection
générale des finances qui a pantouflé
dans le secteur bancaire d'affaires chez
Rothseld puis qui est revenu dans la la
fonction publique comme beaucoup de haut
fonctionnaires qui font des vas et viens
entre la haute fonction la haute finance
privée et la haute finance publique.
Donc ce que je peux raconter pour
illustrer ça, c'est une discussion que
j'ai eu avec des financiers de la City à
Londres il y a quelques mois où on a
passé une journée à la Rail Academy of
Science dans un endroit magnifique
d'ailleurs sur les questions écologiques
et disons le la gravité du désastre
écologique et l'enjeu du financement de
la transition énergétique vers des
énergies renouvelables.
On a eu un certain nombre de discussions
d'abord sur le diagnostic écologique qui
montrait que tout le monde autour de la
table était bien informé. Donc mes
interlocuteurs savaient ont compris que
nous allons versondrements du type
régional continental, que le Sahel est
dans une position extrêmement difficile,
que on va avoir des millions des
dizaines de millions de réfugiés
climatiques qui vont courir dans tous
les sens sur la planète pour aller
chercher un endroit pas hostile à la vie
humaine dans les années qui viennent.
Ils ont compris que euh la fonte du
pergisol, ce qu'on appelle le permafrost
en anglais, aussi bien la surface de la
terre donc en Sibérie, Alaska, Groenland
que sous la mer
avec les hydrates de carbone qui explos
hydrates, voilà,
euh qui vont lâcher du méthane que ça si
ça s'accélère euh ça veut dire qu'on se
prend + 5 6 7 8° et personne ne sait où
ça s'arrête dans les décennies qui
viennent.
Euh et ça ça veut dire que la survie de
l'espèce humaine est en jeu. C'est ça
que ça signifie. Alors aujourd'hui, on n
pas d'évidence empirique qui montre que
euh on en est déjà là, mais on n pas
d'évidence empirique qui montre le
contraire.
Donc il y a un débat extrêmement
intense et angoissé à l'intérieur de la
communauté scientifique sur la mesure
des émissions de méthane euh à la
surface de l'océan Arctique. Voilà. En
fait, on manque de mesures. Euh,
on manque de mesures sur sur ça.
Mais pourtant, j'ai j'ai des copains qui
bochent total au niveau de la
prospection qui me disent voilà quand
les hydrates de carbone ils pètent sous
l'eau, il y a les gouvernements qui
s'excitent parce que ils ont
l'impression qu'il y a des tests de
bombes nucléaires, ils savent pas d'où
ça viennent et ils ont compris depuis un
certain nombre de décennies que ça ça
Ouais. Ouais. Mais malgré tout, non. Les
derniers travaux, y compris ceux qui
sont publiés en 2018, l'an dernier,
montrent qu'en fait, on a un gap entre
les instruments de mesure qu'on a posé
sur terre et la mesure de la densité en
méthane de l'atmosphère à à mi altitude.
Pourquoi ? Parce que on sait pas mesurer
ce qui sort vraiment de l'océan. Donc en
fait, à mi altitude, il y a plus de
méthane que à la surface de la Terre et
le le différentiel entre les deux
pourrait être dû à ce qui ce qui vient
de l'océan. Mais aujourd'hui, c'est pas
démontré. Voilà, donc il y a un débat
là-dessus. Mais la réalité de ce débat
traduit quand même le fait que nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une situation
extrêmement dangereuse.
Tes copains de la City, ils ont fini
comment ? Ils sont un peu bourrés, ils
sont dit "Voilà les gars,
une fois qu'on a dit tout ça, on a dit
bon qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?" Et en gros,
le message de ceux qui étaient là, donc
ils sont pas forcément représentatifs de
la totalité de la city mais en tout cas
d'un certain nombre de financiers qui
ont du pouvoir, ça a été on ne fera rien
nous les Européens. Pourquoi ?
essentiellement parce que
ça nous obligerait à détricoter ce que
nous avons mis 40 ans à mettre en place,
c'est-à-dire la capture du régulateur de
l'absence publique, le démantellement de
l'État providence, l'indépendance de la
banque centrale européenne, la
privatisation des profils, la
mutualisation des des pertes et cetera
et cetera. Évidemment, c'est pas dit de
manière aussi caricaturale et grossière
que ce que je viens de dire, mais c'est
quand même ça le message essentiel. Euh
on n'est pas prêt à disons remettre en
cause le modèle social qu'on a mis en
place hyper inégalitaire euh pour les
questions écologiques. Donc à ce stade
de la discussion avec d'autres, je suis
pas le seul, je demande mais donc que
va-t-il se passer ? Réponse : "Ah, les
Chinois vont faire le boulot." Pourquoi
? Parce que, me dit-on, me dit-il, me
disent-il, la Chine, elle elle a un
pouvoir
dictatorial, non démocratique,
autoritaire qui lui permet de faire le
boulot, le sale boulot et elle va
transiter vers des énergies
renouvelables. C'est le plus gros
pollueur de la planète aujourd'hui, ce
qui est vrai. Donc, on va laisser les
Chinois faire le boulot. Bon, et nous,
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pendant ce
temps-là ? Alors, ils me répondent, ben
nous eux, les financiers,
ces financiers là, on va mettre nos
enfants en Suède parce que avec le
réchauffement climatique, le climat
suédois sera clément, ce qui est
évidemment une illusion parfaite parce
que les incendies des forêts suédoises
l'été dernier ont montré que le les
écosystèmes naturels suédois vont
également souffrir énormément du
dérégèglement climatique. Et au fond, la
migration du vivant de l'équateur vers
les pôles va affecter y compris la Suède
bien sûr. Donc il y a pas d'île déserte
où les très très riches vont pouvoir
aller se cacher.
Un petit bunker.
Non, ils vont devoir se faire des
bunkers mais c'est très désagréable de
vivre dans des bunkers. Je suis allé
visiter des des villages d'expatriés
travaillant dans les hydrocarbossiles en
Afrique.
Donc à l'intérieur du village, vous avez
la piscine, le la salle de concert, le
cinéma, le terrain de tennis, le terrain
de golf et on lave les voitures avec de
l'eau potable. Vous avez des murs
d'enceinte de 5 m de haut, double
épaisseur, mirador, barbelé, chien,
policiers et cetera. De l'autre côté,
les gens n'ont pas d'eau potable à
boire.
Les expates quand ils sortent de ces
villages là montent dans des bus
militarisés. Jeep à l'avant, jeep à
l'arrière, tooky walkiy. On s'arrête pas
au feu rouge, on va sur le site
d'exploitation et on revient.
Madame qui vit là se paye des ps pour
toute sa vie et monsieur
évidemment
se paye des
non enfin je sais pas
des ps pour toute sa vie aussi.
Lui aussi certainement il se paye des ps
aussi. Ouais. Donc ils vont mal et donc
cette vie bunkerisée dans les gated
communities fera souffrir y compris les
plus riches. Mais pour l'instant ils en
ceux que j'ai rencontré, en tout cas
ceux avec qui je parlais ce jour-là à
Londres il y a quelques mois étaient
encore dans cette espèce de fantasme de
il existe une île déserte où on va
pouvoir se cacher et laisser les autres
payer la facture à notre place. Voilà.
Donc ça ça là, il y a un lieu de
résistance très très fort euh
auquel je enfin que je que j'observe.
Voilà, les classes politiques qui sont
actuellement au pouvoir ne sont pas
nécessairement enfermées dans ce cynisme
là. Euh mais elle navigue là-dedans,
c'est compliqué pour elle. Donc elle
navigue entre disons d'un côté les
gilets jaunes ou les gilets rouges en
Tunisie ou d'autres manifestants les les
les lycéens qui vont manifester dans la
rue pour le climat et cetera sur la
planète entière qui leur disent
"Écoutez, ça suffit maintenant, il faut
prendre la question écologique au
sérieux."
de l'autre côté euh un système financier
qui ne prend que très très lentement la
mesure de la gravité de la situation
écologique et de ce que ça implique de
déstabilisation de la sphère financière
elle-même.
Donc vous avez un financier qui l'a dit
de manière très forte en septembre 2015,
c'est Mark Carney, le gouverneur de la
Banque centrale d'Angleterre qui a pour
la première fois et ça a été un vrai
coup de tonner dans la sphère financière
qui a dit la principale menace de la
stabilité financière aujourd'hui c'est
le climat
mais vous avez là-dedans une sphère
financière avec évidemment quelques
financiers qui ont très bien compris la
gravité de l'enjeu et qui essayent de se
démener comme ils peuvent
quelques assureurs qui parce qu'ils font
des pertes de plus en plus fortes à
cause de l'impact du déréglement
climatique commence à comprendre que il
va falloir prendre la chose au sérieux
puisque leur propre business pourrait
être impacté dans les années qui
viennent. Donc vous avez euh le patron
d'Axa qui dit euh il y a 2 ans euh une
planète à 4° Celus n'est pas assurable,
hein. Donc il va y avoir des tels dégâts
sur le patrimoine de capital que nous on
pourra plus assurer. Euh voilà. Mais
tout ça dans un contexte où la très
grande fragilité bilancielle d'un
certain nombre de banques et l'explosion
des dettes privées qui fragilise la
totalité de l'édifice financier fait que
aujourd'hui une bonne partie de la
sphère financière ne sait pas où aller,
que faire. Voyez, elle est prise entre
un volcan qui va exploser, c'est sa
propre son propre craque interne et puis
euh le tsunami qui lui tombe dessus qui
est euh le déréglement climatique. Et
donc là-dedans euh pour l'instant, ils
ont toujours pas euh enfin en tout cas
ceux avec qui je parle n'ont toujours
pas pris de décision forte, en tout cas
collectivement. Et la classe politique
qui est très dépendante de la sphère
financière pour toutes les raisons qu'on
a dit tout à l'heure euh pour l'instant
ne prend pas la mesure de l'urgence
écologique.
Pierre Laroutou, ça te parle ?
Oui, bien sûr, je connais bien, c'est un
ami. Oui.
Son initiative de lever 1000 milliards
pour sauver
le climat.
C'est du wishful sinking. 1000
milliards, c'est pas assez.
Quand tu dis quand tu dis que cette
transition écologique ça va durer 100
ans et ça va coûter très cher, ça coûte
combien
les chiffres ? Alors il y a une bagarre
de chiffres.
Alors en gros, si on veut donc il faut
redonner les enjeux. Les enjeux, c'est
l'accord de Paris, la COP 21 décembre
2015, la communauté internationale
s'engage à faire en sorte que
l'augmentation de la température moyenne
à la surface de la planète à la fin du
siècle n'excède pas plus degr Celus.
Euh, il est vraisemblement trop tard
pour qu'on reste en dessous des 2
degrés. La vraie question, c'est comment
rester le plus proche possible des plus
degrés ? Combien ça va coûter ? C'est
entre disons 50000 et 90000 milliards de
dollars pour les 15 20 années qui
viennent. Donc c'est de l'ordre du PIB
mondial est allé sur 15 ans. Donc ça
fait beaucoup d'argent. Est-ce qu'on a
cet argent ? La réponse est oui. Est-ce
que la sphère financière est prête à le
financer ? La réponse est non.
Aujourd'hui,
alors quand tu dis quand tu dis cet
argent là, oui, c'estàd qu'on a la
capacité de la créer, de faire de la
dette.
Alors, on a on a tous les moyens, on a
la capacité de le créer et on a la
capacité aussi d'aller le chercher parce
qu'il existe déjà. Je veux dire le la
monnaie qui circule sur la planète
aujourd'hui c'est plus de 240000
milliards parce que c'est l'argent qui a
été créé par les banques centrales en
particulier au cours des des 10
dernières années à la faveur des
politiques monétaires non
conventionnelles dites du quantitative
easing d'assouplissement quantitatif qui
ont inondé les marchés interbancaires de
liquidité et qui ont permis aux banques
elles-mêmes de créer énormément d'argent
pour aller jouer sur les marchés
financiers. Donc il y a énormément
d'argent qui circulent. Il y a jamais eu
autant d'argent sur la planète
qu'aujourd'hui. Simplement, il est capté
par le trou noir qui s'appelle les
marchés financiers où cet argent ne sert
pas parce que il n'est pas investi dans
l'économie réelle. On a plus de 90 %
aujourd'hui des transactions financières
sur les marchés financiers qui sont les
transactions entre financiers qui ne
concernent pas l'économie réelle. Voilà.
Donc on peut aller chercher cet argent,
ce capital qui existe déjà.
Comment ?
en faisant la régulation financière et
en médiocrisant, si je puis dire, le
rendement des opérations purement
spéculatives. Une fois que ça rapportera
plus rien, bah cet argent-là va revenir
vers l'économie réelle. Ça c'est
évident. Je dis pas que c'est facile, je
dis pas qu'on peut le faire en 2 jours,
mais disons dans les grands principes,
ça c'est une option. 2è option, utiliser
le pouvoir de création monétaire qui est
à notre disposition que nous avons.
Et vu la gravité des enjeux, si on se
dit que ce qui est en jeu, c'est ne pas
arriver dans une situation où la survie
de l'espèce humaine serait elle-même
menacée, euh je crois que ça vaut la
peine de se poser la question de savoir
si la la création monétaire peut pas
être un outil utile pour financer la à
la fois la transition et l'adaptation
des règlements climatiques déjà
embarqués.
Alors, c'est là que les propositions du
type la rôure rouge en JZel deviennent
intéressantes. En fait, avec un ami qui
s'appelle Alain Grand Jean, il y a 7 8
ans, on avait déjà fait cette
proposition qui consistait à dire
"Écoutez, la Banque centrale européenne
crée aujourd'hui des milliers de
milliards pour les banques, pourquoi ne
créerait-elle pas de l'argent pour
financer
des investissements verts
Bon et j'ai moi-même fait une
proposition au comité des experts pour
le débat national sur la transition
écologique qui avait été initiée par
Delphine Bateau à l'époque la ministre
qui était la suivante. Ce qu'on a fait
avec la société de financement de
l'économie française la SFEF que je vais
décrire dans un instant pour sauver les
banques en 2008 on pourrait le faire
pour sauver la planète. Qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait en 2008 ? En 2008, on a créé la
SFEF en quelques jours. La SFEF, c'est
une société de droits privés abondée par
les banques qui avait la garantie
publique. Qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait avec
le capital des banques ? Elle a emprunté
sur les marchés financiers au taux de la
dette publique française, donc quasi
nulle, euh de l'argent qu'elle a reprêté
aux banques.
À un moment où les banques étaient
tétanisées par la, on est à ce moment-là
en novembre 2018, tétanisé par la faille
de l'emment
je peux plus prêter à ma voisine parce
que peut-être que ma voisine va faire
faillite demain matin. Donc on placé
dans une espèce de comma total le marché
interbancaire de sorte qu'il y avait
plus aucune transaction interbancaire
possible. pour éviter le collapse
généralisé et en particulier la faillite
de nos quatre champions nationaux qui
sans ça n'aurait pas traversé n'aurait
pas survécu à la Saint-Sylvestre 2008,
l'État à ce moment-là construit en
quelques nuits la SFEF, société de
droits privés qui empreinte sur les
marchés avec la garantie publique, donc
au taux d'intérêt de la dette française,
donc quasi nulle, prête en un an plus de
70 milliards aux banques pour qu'elle
puisse passer la Saint-Sylvestre.
Euh
ceci n'a pas été enregistré dans la
dette publique parce que c'était une
société de droits privés.
Et donc vous voyez l'astuce, tu vois
l'astuce c'est tu fais un truc un objet
qui est du droit privé, donc c'est de la
dette privée, mais tu mets la garantie
publique et donc les investisseurs qui
prêtent à cet objet là sa vient que
derrière il y a l'État. Donc il prêtent
en exigeant le taux d'intérêt de l'État.
Taintérêt qui pour la République
française aujourd'hui est toujours nul,
quasi nul, voir à certains moments a été
négatif. pas du tout à cause des vertus
de les finances publiques françaises
puisque on n'est pas on est dans la
moyenne de la zone euro à 100 % du PIB
donc on n'est pas plus ni moins vertueux
que les autres mais parce que les
investisseurs internationaux ont besoin
de diversifier leur portefeuille donc
ils ont besoin de pouvoir mettre leur
argent ou de prêter
à de la dette publique en euros.
Pourquoi ? parce qu'ils ont besoin de ne
pas mettre toutes leur billes dans la
dette privée. Donc il leur faut un peu
de dette publique et ils ont besoin de
ne pas mettre toutes leur billes dans le
dollar ou le yen. Donc il leur faut de
l'euro. Donc quand on croise ces
différents desérats, il faut de la dette
publique en euros. Or de la dette
publique en euros, il y a pas beaucoup
de pays qui en émettent aujourd'hui et
la France est le principal d'entre eux.
Donc les investisseurs à certains
moments sont même prêts à payer la
France pour que la France leur empreinte
en euros.
Ceci étant dit, aujourd'hui on pourrait
très bien faire la même chose. On
pourrait créer une société de
financement de la transition écologique,
société de droits privés qui
emprunterait sur les marchés avec la
garantie publique. Ce serait de la dette
privée, ça n'affecte pas la dette
publique et ça permettrait de financer
les investissements verts. Premièrement.
Deuxièmement, ce qu'on pourrait très
bien faire aussi, c'est négocier avec la
Commission européenne la sortie du
calcul du déficit public des
investissements verts nécessaires à la
survie de l'humanité. Est-ce que c'est
compatible avec les traités ? Donc donc
concrètement, ça voudrait dire on compte
pas dans le 3 % de Mastrift les dépenses
publiques liées aux investissements
verts. Est-ce que c'est compatible avec
les traités européens ? réponse oui
parce qu'en fait les traités européens
autorisent la Commission européenne à
interpréter
le la base le périmètre sur lequel on
calcule le déficit public d'un état.
Jusqu'à présent, la Commission
européenne a toujours interprété le
calcul du déficit public en un sens
maximaliste. On met tout. Mais rien ne
l'empêche demain matin de dire "Bon,
tout bien réfléchi, on n'est pas idiot
donc on sait très bien que les
investissements verts, il faut les
faire, c'est un investissement utile
pour l'humanité. Donc ça, on le sort du
calcul. D'ailleurs, la veille de l'acte
4, si je me souviens bien des gilets
jaunes en décembre mois dernier, le
commissaire européen Pierre Muskovici a
fait une intervention publique en disant
"Bon, on comprend bien que les gens sont
pas contents euh mais en fait, vous
savez, en réalité, on pourrait discuter
du calcul du déficit public de la
manière dont il est fait et on pourrait
se montrer plus conciliant de manière
qu'on ne soit pas obligé de faire des
coupes claires dans les dépenses
publiques au nom du sacross respect de
la règle des 3 %."
Donc il a il l'a dit en fait et il a dit
la vérité. Donc on pourrait très bien
aujourd'hui à périmètre des traités
européens constant renégocier avec le
Bruxelles et donc aussi avec Berlin bien
évidemment euh la définition même du
déficit public que l'on calcule pour la
règle des 3 %. Et puis troisème option.
Donc première option, on pourrait faire
l'équivalent de la SPEF euh pour la
transition. 2è option, on renégocie
l'interprétation l'erméneutique de la du
déficit public. 3è 3è grande option, on
utilise le pouvoir de création monétaire
de la BCE. Donc la BCE a créé plusieurs
milliers de milliards d'euros pour les
banques. Pourrait très bien créer la
même quantité de monnaie juste pour
sauver la planète. Euh comment s'y
prendreon ? On pourrait très bien alors
pour pour expliquer ça, il faut que je
revienne un tout petit peu en arrière.
En 2014, la BCE a déclaré qu'elle était
prête à racheter tous les titres de
créance euh les asset pack securities en
anglais.
Donc faire une bas de banque
des Ouais, pour faire une bas de banque,
on pourrait dire en un sens. Ouais,
c'est pas
une bas de banque.
Une bas de banque, c'est une banque de
défaisance qui prend tous les produits
pourris des banques privées. Alors, je
suis obligé d'ouvrir une parenthèse
puisque tu tu évoques ce terme là.
Beaucoup de banques européennes en
particulier dans les pays dit du sud de
la zone euro ont toujours dans leur
bilan ce qu'on appelle des NPL non
performing loans qui en français courant
s'appelle des actifs pourris qui sont
des actifs hérités de la crise de 2008
qui ne rapportent plus rien, qui ne
valent rien et qui créent des trous
noirs dans les bilans des banques. C'est
ça qui provoque la très très grande
fragilité du secteur bancaire en
particulier de l'Espagne et de l'Italie
et d'une partie du Portugal. Euh aussi
en partie de la France, même si la
France d'abord est quand même moins mal
en point et ensuite ne le dit pas trop
fort. Bon euh
une banque de défaisance, une Bad Bank,
c'est une banque qui récupère tous ces
actifs pourris et qui se fait fort de
les revendre dans un avenir illimité euh
et qui débarrasse la banque privée de la
gestion de ses actifs pourris. Là, ce à
quoi je pense, c'est pas exactement ça
parce que j'espère bien que les crédits
verts qui seraient émis par les banques
privées ne seraient pas les actifs
pourris. Donc l'idée est voisine mais un
tout petit peu différente. L'idée c'est
de dire la BCE fait de la titrisation
pour les banques. Donc en 2014 la BCE
s'est engagé à racheter les titres de
créance des banques euh de quel que
nature qu'il soit. Qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ? C'està dire qu'une banque privée
accorde un crédit et elle se débarrasse
du risque de non remboursement du crédit
qu'elle porte dans son bilan en
transformant cette créance en un actif
financier qu'elle va échanger sur les
marchés. Pour ça elle a besoin d'un
acheteur qui lui achète son actif. La
BCE a donné le signal en 2014, "Faites
du crédit, on vous rachètera le titre de
créance
plus ou moins à n'importe quelle
condition." Euh et à ce moment-là, moi
j'ai une discussion avec François
Hollande où j'ai dit "Mais monsieur le
président, il faut surtout pas faire
ça." Ça c'est refaire la titrisation qui
nous a renvoyé dans le mur en 2008 parce
que la grande crise de subrime était
essentiellement un problème lié à une
titrisation tous azimut qui a fait
n'importe quoi. Euh des châteaux en
Espagne, des villages fantômes et
cetera. Euh donc il faut faire de la
titrisation verte. Il faudrait que la
BCE s'engage à racheter des titres de
créance sur des investissement vert.
François Hollande à ce moment-là m'a dit
excellente idée. Allez dire ça à notre
ami Benoît Curé qui est au bord de la
BCE qui est un français que je connais
bien qui est un ami qui est remarquable.
Euh
voilà et puis
la difficulté c'est que en faisant ça,
on se heurte à une idéologie très forte
aujourd'hui qui est la politique
monétaire. C'est une politique
universelle tous azimut qui ne
privilégie aucun secteur particulier
alors que le vert ça serait un secteur
particulier.
Et donc la réponse qui m'a été faite par
la BCE c'est il est en deux questions
qu'on fasse une politique monétaire
verte. Pourquoi ? parce que ce serait
privilégier un secteur par rapport à un
autre et donc rompre les sacrosins de la
concurrence les sacrosins principe de la
concurrence pure et parfaite. Ce qui est
évidemment une énorme bêtise. Pourquoi ?
Parce que le carbone c'est universel et
le vert c'est universel. Tout doit
devenir vert puisque si on veut avoir
des chances de rester pas trop loin des
plus de degrés à la fin du siècle, il
faut qu'on ait disons la neutralité
carbone nette peu de temps, aussi
peu de temps que possible après 2050.
Ça veut dire que après les 1050, il faut
qu'on émette plus du tout de CO2 ou bien
que les émissions résiduelles de CO2 qui
seront encore
produite à ce moment-là soit entièrement
capté, capturé et stocké.
Je te coupe un peu.
Ouais.
Tu crois tout ça là, tout ce que tu me
racontes depuis une petite demi-heure
là, c'est
Ouais, je pense c'est fondamental. Je
vois pas d'autres Je vois pas d'autres
portes de sortie.
Bah, on se fait une bonne guerre, on
envoie les pauvres se massacrer, on
envahit le Luxembourg avec l'armée, on
diminue la population mondiale et puis
hop, c'est calé. On se fait une petite
politique d'austérité histoire de de
calmer tout le monde. On consomme moins,
on met tous des pulls et puis voilà.
Non, qu'est-ce faut le faire ?
Faut le faire.
Une petite guerre,
une petite guerre, on en aura. Il y en a
déjà. Il faut regarder ce qui se passe
en Syrie. Euh l'effondrement du
Venezuela.
Tout ça n'est pas indépendant du
déréglement climatique. La Syrie, en
fait, la guerre civile syrienne, c'est
une énorme sécheresse entre 2007 et
2010, très mal gérée par le gouvernement
Bachar Alassad qui dégénère et qui
suscite l'explosion sociale.
Il y a pas quelques vautours qu'on
stimuler un peu tout ça ? Non, derrière
bien sûr, mais je veux dire de toute
façon le le dérèglement climatique et
les effondrements provoqués par la crise
écologique ne vont pas se faire comme
dans un film. Oui. Oui, mais tu as
raison. Mais devons pas se faire comme
dans un film d'Hollywood où tout le
monde va voir c'est pas le ciel qui va
nous tomber sur la tête, c'est
Jésus il il arrive quand là ?
Mais Jésus il est déjà là dans la
manière dont chacun a
Ouais dont chacun prend conscience de la
gravité de la situation et du fait que
il y a d'une certaine manière c'est ce
que tu dis il y a il y a deux grandes
options. Il y a l'option chacun pour soi
et Dieu reconnaîtra les chiens pour
tous. C'est l'option de la violence, la
guerre de tous contre tous et le
fantasme d'une petite île déserte où je
pourrais aller me cacher avec mes
enfants. Et il y a l'option de on s'en
sortira pas si on réapprend pas tous
collectivement très très vite à être
solidaire, à travailler ensemble, à
créer des communs, de l'économie
circulaire, de la permaculture et
cetera. Mais ça ça va aussi avec une
puissance publique qui accepte de
financer les infrastructures vertes dont
on a besoin. Sinon, on n'y arrivera pas.
Pourquoi ? Parce que les petits gestes
du quotidien, j'aurais dû dire ça tout à
l'heure, les petits gestes du quotidien
et ce que tu as appelé les communautés
IPI sympathiques qui à mon avis sonturé
à dessin ou pas de problème.
Ça ça nous permet de faire quoi ? Ça
fait ça diminue notre empreinte carbone
de 20 % 25 % si on est héroïque. On met
beaucoup de pull, plus d'avion, plus de
viande rouge, plus de viande blanche et
mais 25 % ça suffit pas, il faut passer
à zé donc suffit pas de passer de 100 à
75, il faut passer de 100 à 0.
Et pour ça, il faut que la totalité de
l'électricité qu'on consomme, celle de
ce truc qui m'éclaire, tout ça, la
caméra, tout ça, ça provient d'énergie
renouvelable. C'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui.
L'énergie renouvelable comme comme tu
l'aimes à les appeler.
Ouais.
Quand on en discute avec les
énergéticiens, ça les fait marrer.
Quand on discute avec deux trois autres,
il nous disent que il y a beaucoup de
green green washing, green bullshit.
Tout à fait. Ça me permet, j'ai pas fini
d'ailleurs ma ma petite démonstration
tout à l'heure sur la BCE, mais
tu dois partir à quelle heure déjà ?
Euh 12h et 15, donc dans 20 minutes. Eu,
juste, je termine ma petite
démonstration de tout à l'heure. La BCE,
qu'est-ce qu'elle devrait faire ? Et ça
me permettra d'embrayer sur le green
washing. Ce que devrait faire la BCE,
c'est racheter les titres de créance
vertes des banques.
Comme ça, les banques ne portent aucun
risque dans leur bilan. Elles peuvent
faire du crédit vert autant qu'elles
veulent. C'est pas elle qui assume le
risque et c'est la BCE qui assume le
risque. Évidemment, si la BCE fait des
pertes, normalement d'après les règles
de l'euro, elle doit être recapitalisée
par les pays de la zone euro au prorata
de leur propre PIB. Bon, et c'est
évidemment ça aussi qu'il faut
renégocier. Je veux dire, il faut
accepter de ne pas recapitaliser la BCE.
Enfin bon, euh mais oui, si elle fait
des pertes, elle fait des pertes et elle
crée de la monnaie. Voilà, c'est des
pertes qu'il faut assumer parce que
c'est les pertes nécessaires pour que
nous apprenions la transition
écologique. Alors après, il se pose la
question de quel sont les
investissements verts qu'il faudrait
qu'elle finance. Est-ce qu'elle rachète
n'importe quel type de créance ? La
réponse est évidemment non parce que
malheureusement notre imagination est
sans limite pour faire du green washing.
ce qui est le le thème que tu abordes
euh aujourd'hui par exemple, je crois
malheureusement que la totalité des
investissements qui sont financés par ce
qu'on appelle les green bonds, les
obligations vertes sont du green
washing. Pourquoi ? parce que on observe
sur les marchés qu'il y a aucune
différence de rendement entre une
obligation verte et une obligation
brune. Donc si le marché financier price
exactement de la même manière ces deux
types d'obligations, ça veut dire qu'il
sait parfaitement qu'il y a aucune
différence dans l'investissement
sous-jacent à ces deux obligations.
D'où viennent ces obligations vertes ?
malheureusement probablement de la
volonté d'un certain nombre de
financiers après 2009 de faire croire à
l'opinion publique que enfin la finance
s'est mise au vert est devenue vertueuse
et sert à quelque chose. Malheureusement
c'est pas le cas. Les obligations vertes
sont une immense opération de green
washing. Donc évidemment, il y a un vrai
enjeu qui est déterminer, identifier et
discerner quels sont les vrais
investissements verts. Or, pour ça, on a
un atout en Europe qui est la Banque
européenne d'investissement qui est une
banque qui sait qui a une vraie
expertise dans les investissements verts
qui est unanimement reconnu et donc on
pourrait très bien imaginer un
dispositif dans lequel la BUI finance
avec le secteur privé et les États les
investissements verts dont nous avons
besoin. Elle donne son label, ce qui est
une garantie du fait qu'on fait pas du
green washing. Et la BCE s'engage à
racheter les titres créances de la BUI
de manière qu'elle puisse le faire à
très très grande échelle. Ce dont on a
besoin, c'est plusieurs milliers de
milliards d'euros tous les ans au niveau
de la zone euro. C'est des sommes
colossales mais à moins de ça, on y
arrivera pas. Je vois pas comment on
passe d'un monde aujourd'hui où 80 % de
l'énergie que nous dissipons, c'est de
l'énergie fossile, hydrocarbure. Euh
d'un monde où la consommation du charbon
augmente sur cette planète à un monde
qui viserait la neutralité carbone en
2060.
Euh là euh question d'internet.
l'Assemblée nationale qui vote la
privation d'ADP à aéroport Paris à 6h15.
Vous en pensez quoi ? C'est c'est un bon
truc parce que dans certaines
conférences vous dites que bah il y aura
plus d'avion, que on va plus prendre
l'avion, que voilà. Donc c'est peut-être
une super opération du gouvernement
Macron en fait non ?
Alors j'ai dis pas qu'il y aura plus
d'avion. J'ai dit que il faut qu'on
prenne beaucoup beaucoup moins l'avion
et que on réserve l'avion aux opérations
ultra urgentes et nécessaire impérative.
Prévoit le trafic a rien qui double.
Ouais. Oui, ça c'est une énorme bêtise.
Donc ça c'est un premier aspect. C'est
sûr que relever le défi écologique passe
par renoncer à prendre l'avion sinon
pour des cas d'extrême urgence
nécessaire et cetera. Deuxièmement, il y
a un deuxième sujet qui est la
privatisation de l'aéroport de Paris.
C'est un sujet extrêmement débattu
aujourd'hui, y compris dans la classe
politique. Euh, il y a une espèce de
consensus à droite et à gauche pour
critiquer cette décision.
De mon point de vue, elle participe
d'une optique globale qui est la
privatisation du monde. Et ça, c'est une
des racines du problème auquel nous
sommes confrontés aujourd'hui.
C'est-à-dire croire que la propriété
privée, qui est une invention tout à
fait récente en fait hein, surtout la
propriété privée au sens nous
l'entendons aujourd'hui serait l'alpha
et l'oméga des relations sociales et
notre rapport au monde. En fait, c'est
faux. Euh cette idée, cette conception
contemporaine de la propriété privée,
elle s'origine autour du 17e siècle
anglais, notamment chez des gens comme
HS et Lock euh qui en font disons
l'attribut de la souveraineté absolue
chez HPS du despot dans un monde
totalitaire, le Léviatan, chez Loc du
propriétaire bourgeois privé, euh les
révolutionnaires français dans le code
civil et puis les les donc les juristes
napoléoniens ont hérité de cette
compréhension là de la propriété privée,
en ont fait un droit sacré et
inviolable, mais ont laissé ouverte la
porte euh à une propriété partagée, à
des communs et surtout ont une
conception non absolutiste de la
propriété privée qui peut toujours, y
compris dans le droit civiliste
français, être démantelé dans les trois
piliers de la propriété privée, à savoir
l'Ozus, le Fructus et la BOUS qui sont
les trois composants du de la du droit
de propriété euh construite par les
théologiens médiévaux après la réforme
géorienne du 11e siècle. Ce qui s'est
passé, c'est qu'au 11e siècle, les
juristes et les théologiens médiévaux
ont redécouvert le codex de Justinien,
donc en fait le droit romain, euh l'ont
réécrit, adapté, interprété, théologisé,
bon et ont hérité du coup de la
propriété privée romaine
et lui ont donné trois composantes : le
droit d'usage, le droit de détruire Bous
et le droit de revendre, de fruct de
faire fructifier Fructus. Aujourd'hui,
je pense que ce qu'il faut que nous
apprenions à faire, c'est à désarticuler
ces trois composantes et à donner la
prééminence absolue au droit d'usage à
l'Ozus sans détruire et sans vouloir
vendre la planète qu'on a pas d'acheteur
pour cette planète. Voilà.
Autre question internet. Peut-on
craindre une hausse des taux directeurs
si possible
et si possible expliquer ce que ce
qu'est un taux directeur ?
Donc la banque centrale en fait
elle prête aux banques de second rang
aux banques privées sur le marché
interbancaire.
Euh à chaque fois qu'une banque privée
accorde un crédit, justement les règles
prudentielles de bal 3 dont je parlais
tout à l'heure l'oblige à avoir un petit
peu de fond propre correspondant au
crédit supplémentaires qu'elle vient
d'accorder.
Euh si elle bon et voilà si elle manque
de ses fonds propres euh et surtout si
elle manque de monnaie banque centrale.
Donc il lui faut aussi d'après ses rés
prudentielles disposer un peu de monnaie
banque centrale. C'est la monnaie qui
est créée par la banque centrale. Alors
elle doit se refinancer en monnaie
banque centrale. La monnaie banque
centrale, c'est la monnaie que vous et
moi n'avons jamais vu, sauf si vous avez
été banquier. Euh parce que c'est la
monnaie qui ne circule que dans le
marché interbancaire entre la banque
centrale et les banques. La monnaie qui
est dans sur votre sur ton compte en
banque ou dans le portefeuille, ça c'est
la monnaie disons qui est émise par les
banques de second rang. C'est la monnaie
de tous les jours. La monnaie banque
centrale c'est la monnaie, c'est pas la
monnaie de tous les jours. C'est une
monnaie qui est une monnaie miroir des
transactions monétaires que nous avons
dans la vie réelle.
Les banques à chaque fois qu'elles font
des transactions dans la vie réelle
doivent faire des transactions miroir en
reflet entre elles en monnaie banque
centrale. Donc par exemple lorsque moi
j'achète un appartement avec admettons
que je t'achète un appartement en fait
je vais demander à ma banque de créditer
ton compte de dépôt de l'argent que je
te paye. Ton compte de dépôt il est dans
une autre banque. Donc ma banque à moi
mais donc sur la banque A doit créditer
la ton compte de dépôt dans la banque B
de la somme que je paye pour acheter ton
appartement. En fait, elle a 15 jours ma
banque pour normaliser sa situation
vis-à-vis de ta banque, de la banque B.
Simplement, pendant ces 15 jours, il est
très probable que la banque B elle-même
fasse des opérations dans l'autre sens
avec d'autres clients de la banque A,
pas forcément moi, mais quelqu'un
d'autre. Donc, plutôt que de tout faire
à chaque fois en reflet, en miroir de
toutes les transactions qu'il y a dans
l'économie réelle, ce qui serait
monstrueux, tous les 15 jours, en gros,
les banques entre elles appurent leur
position, c'est qu'elles font le net
uniquement. Admettons que ma banque A
pour ton appartement doivent 100 à ta
banque à la banque B. Mais dans le même
temps, la banque B doit 75 à ma banque A
à moi. Donc dans 15 jours, ce que va
faire la banque A, c'est juste donner 25
à la banque B. Cette transaction là,
elle s'opère en monnaie banque centrale,
pas en monnaie de tous les jours. Cette
monnaie banque centrale, si elle n'en a
pas assez, elle est obligée de
l'emprunter soit auprès des autres
banques, soit auprès de la banque
centrale. À quel taux ? essentiellement
pour aller vite au taux directeur fixé
par la banque centrale. Donc la banque
centrale avec ce taux directeur, elle
contrôle en fait l'aptitude des banques
privées à euh à accorder du crédit,
hein.
Quand elle augmente le taux directeur,
ça rend les crédits plus coûteux pour
les banques privées puisque ça rend plus
coûteux pour elle le fait de se
refinancer comme les banques centrales.
Quand elle baisse ce taux, ça rend le
crédit moins coûteux.
La fait aux États-Unis est en train
aujourd'hui d'essayer de sortir des
politiques monétaires non
conventionnelles qu'elle a mise en œuvre
pendant des années en augmentant son
taux progressivement.
Euh la BCE pour l'instant ne le fait pas
et je ne crois pas du tout qu'elle
puisse le faire dans les mois qui
viennent à cause justement de la
fragilité bilancielle de toute une série
de banques dans la zone eure.
La déflation c'est bien. Le japonais il
a connu ça, il sait pas comment en
sortir.
On va expérimenter ça en Europe, ça va
être bien. Alors autre question
d'internet. Que pensez-vous des
mouvements de désobéissance civile ?
Vous qui avez fait vœu d'obéissance ?
Alors euh donc moi j'ai fait vœux
d'obéissance auprès de mes autorités
religieuses.
Le personne est parfait hein.
Euh alors je cumule je cumule. Tu vas me
dire parce que je suis religieux puis je
suis aussi fonctionnaire au
fonctionnaire. Donc j'ai un devoir de
réserve vis-à-vis de l'État et cetera.
Macron Macron c'est ton copain ?
C'est c'est mon président président de
la République. Donc
tu peux rien dire.
Donc j'ai un devoir de réserve. Vous
avez du président ce qui est normal.
Euh,
est-ce que les Est-ce que les religions
c'est pas un peu caduc ? Est-ce que
l'homme a pas besoin de se défaire de la
religion une bonne fois pour toute pour
se réapproprier son destin ?
Je crois pas du tout. Pour la raison
suivante, c'est que le sens profond du
vœu d'obéissance religieux, c'est le
suivant. c'est que je pense que nous
faisons tous l'expérience, toi comme
moi, les gens qui nous écoutent, que
nous avons un désir de vie profond qui
nous habite, mais que euh moi je ne sais
pas exactement où me conduit ce désir.
Donc le doute,
non, c'est pas c'est pas une question de
doute, c'est une question de c'est c'est
le problème de mon fils, tu feras
polytechnique. Le père qui dit ça à son
fils est un salot parce que il ne sait
pas si son fils sera heureux. Si Félix,
peut-être qu'il sera très malheureux,
peut-être qu'il a envie de faire les
beaux. Ça c'est le désir de vie profond
du fiston ou de la fille, peu importe.
Et donc lui-même non plus ne sait pas. À
15 ans, il sait pas s'il sera heureux
d'aller à l'X ou aller faire les
beauxards en gros, à part de rares
exceptions d'adolescents très très murs,
quoi. Donc j'ai besoin de découvrir où
me conduit mon désir profond. Le vœu
d'obéissance religieux, c'est je crois
que d'obéir à mon désir de vie profond,
c'est ça qui me rend heureux. Donc c'est
pas une espèce d'aliénation à une
hétéronomie fondamentale qui serait je
sais pas quoi, une espèce de QG de
religieux qui contrôlerait le monde
quelque part au Vatican. C'est je fais
l'expérience que je ne suis pas
transparent à moi-même, qui a un
fantasme de transparence dont il faut
euh dont il faut faire le deuil et que
je souhaite être obéissant au désir de
vie qui est en moi pour être heureux.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire être
obéissant au désir de vie qui est en moi
? Comme je fais l'expérience que je suis
pas transparent, ça passe par d'autres.
J'ai la besoin de la médiation d'autrui
pour apprendre petit à petit où me
conduit mon désir. La psychanalyse dans
son domaine à elle ne fait pas autre
chose. Le gars qui fait une analyse, il
va voir un psychanalyste et il lui parle
pour que ce psychanalyste soit un tiers
qu'il aide lui, le gars qui fait
l'analyse à petit à petit entendre et
comprendre et
voir où le le conduit son désir profond.
Tu connais Chrin Murti ? Chris
Krishna Murti
non
regarde des sa conférence de 1985 à
l'ONU.
D'accord.
Autre question d'internet.
Oui.
Que diriez-vous aux catholiques qui
travaillent dans les banques d'affaires
?
Et bien je leur dirais qu'il faut qu'il
lisent la déclaration d'octobre 2011 du
Conseil pontifical de Justice et paix et
qu'il se pose des questions sur leur
compromission dans ce qu'on appelle
entre catholiques des structures de
péchés.
Donc je connais des câaux financiers qui
ont démissionné leur poste une fois
qu'ils ont pris conscience du fait
qu'ils étaient complices d'un système
qui n'est pas socialement utile.
Il faut pas leur dire de démissionner,
il faut leur dire de rester, de faire
les taupes, de miner le système de
l'intérieur et voilà.
Va leur dire le point c'est euh
jusqu'où j'ai une vraie liberté de
manœuvre ? Qu'est-ce que je peux changer
dans le système ? Voilà, c'est
compliqué. Euh, il y a de tout. Donc,
j'ai des discussions passionnantes avec
des financiers qui sont pris là-dedans,
qui se disent exactement ce que tu dis,
c'est-à-dire est-ce que je ferais mieux
de rester pour euh continuer de mettre
un peu d'humanité dans toute cette
affaire, limiter la casse euh et être là
un peu d'éthique, voilà. Où est-ce qu'il
vaut mieux que je quitte parce que la je
suis trop compromis dans ce à quoi je
participe ? Ça c'est ça, c'est un
discernement qu'on peut pas faire à leur
place, euh qui est compliqué, qu'il faut
qui demande beaucoup de maturité. Voilà.
que je peux auquel sur lequel évidemment
je peux absolument pas me substituer à
la personne en question. Au contraire,
trois bouquins à conseiller à notre
communauté.
Trois bouquins à lire.
Euh donc le manifeste de Delphine bateau
écologie intégrale
qui vient de sortir
euh
mon petit livre Illusion financière où
on retrouve une bonne partie de tout ce
qu'on s'est dit là depuis 2 heures et
puis un troisème euh bah quand même
l'encyclique là au dat aussi je suis sûr
qu'il y a une bonne partie de ceux qui
nous écoutent qui l'ont pas lu.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose d'impérissable. C'est
on finit toujours notre notre émission
comme ça.
D'accord. Oui, j'ai un conseil à leur
donner qui est euh moi ma perception
c'est que la jeune génération
est disons est tentée par d'un côté une
espèce de désespoir profond face à la
gravité de la situation. De l'autre,
l'envie de faire un procès définitif à
la génération du dessus sur le thème,
voilà, sur le thème, vous nous laissiez
une planète inhabitable, criblé de
dettes, où on aura pas de travail, enfin
c'est la la génération ninja quoi. No
income, no job, no asset. Euh, je
comprends très bien cette colère là et
elle me semble en grande partie
justifiée. Il reste que cette jeune
génération pourra pas tout faire toute
seule. Elle a besoin absolument de
trouver des alliés dans la génération du
dessus.
Alors évidemment, quand j'ai dit ça,
j'apparais comme me mettant moi-même
comme candidat pour être un de ses
alliés et c'est vrai. Mais je pense
qu'elle doit absolument faire un
discernement pour savoir qui dans la
génération du dessus est un allié peut
aider et qui n'est pas un allié. Voilà.
Et donc un ennemi
et un ennemi et donc si elle ne fait pas
ce discernement là et qu'elle envoie
tout le monde à la guillotine, elle va
elle-même être confrontée à des
problèmes monstrueux qu'elle pourra pas
résoudre toute seule. Je crois pas. Il y
a un fantasme là de la de la solution
expéditive qui est dont il faut faire le
deuil. Peut-être que c'est une manière
de me sauver moi-même, mais je crois
pas. C'est-à-dire je fais la même
expérience moi-même avec la génération
du dessus. Euh il faut on peut pas tout
faire tout seul et tout résoudre tout
seul. On a besoin aussi de l'expérience
des autres. euh y compris la génération
d'avant. Et donc, il y a un vrai travail
de discernement à faire et un travail de
conviction. Voilà. Ce qui n'empêche pas
de garder euh euh intacte et très vive
la colère de la jeune génération
aujourd'hui. Au contraire.
Gelgirou, merci.
Merci.
[Musique]